in this Godot game development course
you will learn how to build a 3D action
role-playing game if you've been wanting
to learn how to create 3D games this is
the course for you whether you already
have experience with Godot or whether
you're brand new to it you will learn a
lot in this course Omar Zaki is an
experienced game developer and he
created this course some of the key
topics you will learn about include 3D
World creation character creation with a
complex animation tree inventory systems
with dictionaries and simple AI monster
systems so let's get started with a
giant number of courses out there there
are so many different courses to choose
from and you decided to look at this one
now you're probably wondering what does
this course have to do and what can I
actually offer you that other courses
don't well
be hard to pinpoint the uniqueness of a
course but my course is focusing on
three things I can't promise you
uniqueness however I can promise that
you will exit this course going from I
don't know anything about 3D to being a
somewhat intermediate user for 3D and
you'll be able to go on on your own and
learn more about 3D stuff
and create your own game hopefully now
the three well four points that you're
going to learn specifically in this
course
we're going to learn one about 3D World
creation so we're going to go over a
bunch of different things like
environments setting up different tile
Maps Etc so we're going to go over the
creation of a 3D world that you will be
able to create
the second thing that we're going to do
is character creation with complex
animation tree now characters can be
created in so many different ways now
one of the issues when it comes to 3D or
any or 2D or 3D is animating now in 3D
adding animation grows your options
exponentially but it exponentially gets
harder and I'm going to go over the very
Basics just from animation player all
the way into animation tree and we're
also going to go into States and state
machines now I'm going to go over the
complete basics of everything and I hope
that you will able to take everything
that you learn and create your own
character in the future
the next part is dictionaries and an
inventory system now creating an
inventory system can be pretty complex
in of itself however I'm going to
simplify that with dictionaries so we're
going to go over in-depth dictionary
explanations and you're going to leave
this course hopefully a master of
dictionaries and not only will you be
able to create another inventory system
of your own but you will be able to
adapt your inventory system to however
you like
and the last thing it's not super
complex but we're going to be creating a
simple AI monster system you'll be able
to create a world of various different
monsters that you can choose from that
you can add to the to your game or to
any other game that you create
so I hope you guys are ready for this
course this course I hope you will have
a lot of fun in and good luck
hey welcome everyone this is going to be
the first part to our Series so first up
is we're going to go through the packs
that we have and the options that we
have so the first option is going to be
the kkit pack so first off we have two
sections to this game we have the
Character Pack and we have the
environment packs so for the characters
I'm going to be going through two
different ways of doing this we're going
to go through the K kit animations going
with the animations and the character
skeletons I have made a video on this
before but we will include it in this
series as well and the second option is
going to be the meek Samo Character Pack
so these got this is also another site
that allows you to have a lot of
different character packs
and we'll be going through the process
of implementing this into the dough as
well so that's two options that we have
that we will be covering in this series
so you'll have two options on that point
and next up we have the simple grass
texture this is just a very easy kind of
plug-in for Godot that allows us to as
you can see add grass so this is really
cool you can download it down below and
I'll kind of be showing that into our
game later on next up is our environment
pack so for environment packs we have a
few options this K kit dungeon pack goes
with the K kit animations and stuff but
it's up to you really so another option
for the environment pack is going to be
these two the modular Village and
modular terrain packs so these two kind
of go together they're from the same
artist these are actually kind of cool
because
um they have this artist has a
um way to kind of uh build this I think
it's masked this guy so you can have you
can implement this I think you have to
buy it so it's not just for Unity I
think it's a third-party software that
you can build essentially to uh stuff
like this outside of Godot and then
re-import it into good I'm not 100 sure
we're not going to cover that we're just
going to be doing most our work in the
dough so it's just up to you and what
you want to pick but this is a viable
option next up is the actual item pack
so this is going to be for inventory
stuff so this is kind of important we're
not going to use all of it but it's free
and so you can download a few items from
this or just download this pack and
we'll be using it later on
okay and lastly these the uh Dev pack
and the dev assets pack so here we're
actually only going to be using the fire
starter guy and it sounds a bit silly
but that's kind of mainly all we're
going to use obviously there's more
stuff so that you can use it if you'd
like so there's uh weapons
um fences and you can just build
whatever you like we'll be going through
everything you need to know to set up
everything together so the first thing
we're going to do is make sure we
actually export each folder that we need
so here I have exported them already
through each separate folder and I want
you to make your own let's make our
project so I've already made it but I'm
going to just show you how to actually
do that in case you don't know so real
quick we just open up Godot we go to new
project as you already saw we're going
to go to
you can put it wherever you want I put
on desktop you can click browse browse
wherever you want create the folder and
we're going to use forward plus you can
always change this later but um we're
going to use four plus for now and then
I use none so that's what I did and then
I created create and edit and let's open
up my project
so the first things we're going to do is
I'm going to delete these so you're not
confused so here we're going to go into
our project setting we're going to
change a few things well two things so
the first thing that you're probably
going to want to do is change texture
here to texture default to nearest what
I'm going to use linear we're going to
use nearest and in case you don't see
all these settings we're going to go to
advanced settings on the top right
next up we're going to go to window and
go through a few different options so
for the mode I'm going to be using
windowed but you're more than welcome to
use whatever else you want maximized
full screen it doesn't matter
now for the stretch we're going to be
using canvas item the reason is because
when I have something that I draw on the
screen so if you're looking at my face
and I drop Drew something on my face and
I increased this entire screen I want
this item to be expanded as well now if
it's not canvas items that won't happen
if we have it on disabled it won't work
so that's why we need on camera's items
okay so here as you can see I've already
made a 3D scene we're going to save this
and as world and we're going to run it
and it'll prompt you to select current
so we'll select current and run our
first screen so this is just our 3D
world there's nothing in it yet so we
can't even notice that it's 3D and next
up we're going to actually edit a few
things in our animation pack so the
first thing we have to realize is that
there's a lot of different ways to have
a 3D item so
I mean minimize these
so the 3D items or 3D objects can be
stored as different types of objects so
here let's go into models go to
characters and here we can see there's
different types of things so we have
object fbx and Dae here I'm going to
delete these three and leave gltf I'm
going to delete them because they're
going to take up too much space and
we're going to go to assets and same
thing let's delete all three of those
and let's go to Resource we don't need
that let's delete these let's close this
let's go to dungeon and we're gonna have
to do the same thing here so we're going
to go to samples we don't need that
let's delete all those and delete
everything except for gltf
let's go back here
okay and last I up is the which one did
I not edit
I think it was the animation yeah
awesome okay so here we go let's go to
the animations we're going to delete the
fbx we're going to go to documentation
we don't need that we don't need the
resources the model I don't believe we
need but we're gonna play with it
anyways we're gonna delete everything
except for the GLT
I'm gonna delete all those whoops delete
not enter all right awesome now we've
deleted everything that we don't need
let's import those into our game
okay now that we've imported everything
let's maximize our screen again and take
a look at what we have so the first
thing we're going to actually use is
probably our character skeletons pack so
we're not going to make our character
just yet
we're going to we're not going to
animate it just yet but we're going to
make it so let's go to character body 3D
and create it as a separate
screening so here we'll rename it to
Flair
now let's add a few things that we need
so Collision
shape we're going to create it as a
sphere
so here we'll make it as big as we want
we'll move it up and lastly let's
actually add our mesh so what is a mesh
well that's a great question I'm glad
you asked so let's open up our Character
Pack we're not going to go to the assets
because I think those are weapons and
stuff so here we're going to use our
base character where is it the minion
that's the base one so here if we drag
it out a little bit we can read it and
say it says character skeleton minion I
think broken is just the bones are
broken
yeah that one has like a thing in his
head yeah this one doesn't so we're
going to drag this guy in and here we
can see that we have our node 3D now we
if we double click this guy this pops up
and here we have a bunch of meshes so
the mesh itself is simply the drawing
essentially the skeleton so here we can
look at each one separately and we have
the eyes the head Etc we have so many
things we have the hand and we'll close
this
and what we'll do is when we drag this
in it ends up being a node 3D array so
here's our node 3D what you can do is
inherit this and say new inherited and
this will pop up but we don't want this
we don't want to save this and then
reload it what we can do instead is is
what is happening
there we go
oh that's really weird
okay let's delete this and drag that
back in
okay that was a weird bug hopefully we
edit that out uh okay so here what we'll
do instead is we'll right click this and
we'll go to make local now what we can
do is take all these guys out or no
actually we'll leave this in so now we
have all the meshes and we just leave
the node 3D to kind of contain all these
meshes so now we have all the meshes as
a local thing so now I can like make the
head invisible for some reason or the
eyes or the jaw I'm not sure why but you
know we we now have that option right so
now we've made everything local
and now we have our player so let's
actually make a new folder for our
player
we're going to have everything we put in
our player there so let's save it
let's go to our player make a new script
we're going to use the template basic
movement let's put it in and now let's
add a camera 3D
now for the camera 3D we're just going
to place it up of him for now just so we
can kind of see the game so let's kind
of rotate it so that it's looking at our
player
so here we have the red guy that rotates
it right we have the blue one that will
rotate it to the other way and that's it
so here we can have the camera looking
at the player so if I were to play
nothing would happen because in our
world we don't have our player yet now
let's actually drag our player in so
let's add this guy in
and play and see what happens
and most likely nothing will happen so
we can see our player he's upside down
so what we're going to do is we're going
to go to our camera we most likely
rotate it the wrong way yeah so let's
actually do that this way
nope
let's do
like that there we go let's rotate this
guy 180.
the Y and then we'll just drag this down
just a little bit there you go and now
we have it rotated properly so that
little triangle on the top means that
it's pointing up so here in our world
let's add a floor so that we can
actually walk on something so it's out
of collision but obviously we need a
static body to hold that Collision
well let's add a shape
let's give it a box and let's just make
it really wide wrong way
there we go
and let's drag this up a little bit and
so here we should fall down well we
should but we won't because
actually we've already added our skip so
let's see what happens let's see if we
fall down
okay here we go so here we can see that
our player is in and if we try moving
it seems like nothing is happening well
that's because we have nothing as a
reference so why don't we try adding a
mesh to our our
lore so let's make a mesh instance let's
go here and we'll say mesh box
and in our mesh box we'll just drag it
using these guys or we can actually just
use this and make it bigger so let's
drag it out
Make it try to fit it make it fit the
floor of the actual Collision
here we go
and there we go there's our floor so now
let's play and see what we got so now we
can see our actual floor and we can see
that it's moving around now you might
notice that the directions might not be
working properly like if I go up I'm
going back if I go down I'm going
forward if I try clicking to the right
it's going to go to the left but that's
okay we're not going to worry too much
about this because we're going to be
actually changing the player um controls
and everything ourselves so
but that's it for now so we now have a
floor and player so that's good
um one last thing we're going to do
before I end this part is we're going to
add the environment so what is an
environment well that's a great question
I'm so happy you asked
an environment is something that will
essentially allow us to change the
environment around us and as you notice
we added it and it changed so much
already so let's let me just pull up my
reference so I have
the environment settings I made okay so
the first thing I'm going to do is
actually create an environment so we
have to go here to the top and say new
environment
and we're going to go in here and we can
now edit a bunch of things now here we
have a lot of different options but
we're not going to play with all of them
however if you want certain effects like
for example glow or fog this is a great
option because now we have fog glow
there's so many different things you can
do with environment now the main thing
we're going to do to actually make this
feel like a 3D action game is we want to
go to background
we're going to change it to Sky we're
going to go to the actual sky this
option should pop up we'll change we'll
go to Sky and say new Sky we're going to
go to
the sky material we're going to make it
a procedural
Sky material there we go and now in here
where the radiance size we'll do 128
and here I don't think I change anything
oh no I lied I did do some things here
is where we can actually change the
color of the sky so let's go to oops
let's go to top color and I used like a
little bit of a more white because now
it kind of feels like a white Sky you're
more than welcome to do like a light
blue maybe whatever you like and then
for the Horizon color I use kind of a
darkish blue not darkish blue but kind
of
you wish so that's like the Horizon
right so now we see the Horizon there
and here you can change whatever you
like you have that verb curve and change
whatever you like so you can play around
with things right so we have the energy
multiplier cover you can play around
with this but those are the settings I'm
going to be using
and no that's it actually that's it for
the environment so we now have a sky
with a uh Sun so what happened well here
we can now see our shadow it's why we
have a shadow because we've just added
the environment so in our game you might
not see it but that's okay we're going
to be adding things in later that will
actually allow us to do that so that's
it for this part I'm going to be showing
you guys how to import a character from
mix Samo as well this is going to be
another separate part so one of the
things that we should keep in mind is
here there's no animation player but
we'll be using the kkit animation later
on to set it up so you will have two
different options to set up this
character the cake hit or the mcsamo
character now in this series I will most
likely be using the kkit character for
most of the stuff however just keep in
mind you'll see later but once
everything is set up it's basically the
same so you don't have to worry about oh
what if uh this it's a little different
and I can't follow along don't worry it
took me exactly the same this character
eventually will have an animation player
here with like idle run and stuff like
that and the external character will
also have that so you'll see in a minute
so let's get started let's first
obviously
um okay so the first thing I have to do
is go to the main website you have to
log in so make sure you're actually
logged in because I don't think it'll
let you download assets unless you
logged in so here
let's go to the characters and pick a
character so the character I would
recommend picking is one with a prop so
we have two options I'm gonna pick this
one for uh so I don't get demonetized
um and then we're gonna download it so
we're gonna do FPS download boom boom
boom awesome and now we're going to you
can look through all the other
characters and pick whatever you want
now just keep in mind this one has a
sword a built-in sword and that's kind
of important because what's going to
happen is if we try to put one without a
sword and attack for example it's not
gonna really work properly so let's just
keep that in mind whoops so we're gonna
need idle
let's look up idle so let's look for an
idle animation that we want we can pick
Maybe
let's pick this one
yeah
um let's try to make some things kind of
short because the longer the loops on
the bottom we can see here that this was
50 frames and the other one was 300 a
longer frame is going to just be a
little harder on video but it was
obviously not the best 3D engine so
we're going to try to pick ones that are
a little easier so that was an idle one
let's find a walk animation
see
now okay here's the main issue when it
comes to Godot so Godot has an issue
when things walk forward like this so
what we're going to do is we're going to
make him in place so we're going to make
him walk in place
awesome so this is one option so let's
download this you know fbx all the
default settings block
now let's look for a attack whoops I
guess they finished downloading attack
so you can pick anything you want just
keep in mind we have to try to look for
one where he's in place
okay
these are all really weird attacks
okay I think I'm gonna fix that one yeah
let's pick this one let's download it
and the last one we need is jump
now there is two things to keep in mind
so
um
this
I think it's this one
I think this is the one I used not 100
sure let's look through them together we
can use this one yeah that one's a full
one so you want to look for a full
animation from start to finish so
there's not going to be a falling
animation that we're gonna Implement
we're just gonna do the full jump let's
pick this one
one other thing to keep in mind in mxaml
there is
if I go here I can search up pack I
think yeah and we have these packs so
these packs are like magic on for
example you can look for one that's for
this character so I think it'll be
scrolled out here we go sword and shield
pack now
it's a little hard to download this pack
and actually use it for a few different
reasons one because you'll see later in
blender it doesn't really work that well
but two because some of them like
walking they they're not in place and we
can't change that so I would recommend
just doing everything
um separately and and just doing every
every download that you need as a sync
file
okay so now let's go to our game
and let's import everything so first
let's create a new folder so I don't get
confused let's say mix ammo
layer
okay and now let's open up blender
so let's look up blender
and open it up and now here's the fun
part so we have to basically import our
fbx folders into blender and Export it
again as a gltf now first of all as you
can see I deleted everything in our
scene so delete everything under scene
collection now let's go to file import
and we're going to import as an fbx
let's find the files that we used
so first we're going to import the
Paladin with prop we're not going to
import anything else just the prop guy
just the actual t-pos so give it a
second it'll load the character and you
should be able to see our character as a
t pose so here now what you can do is
import the rest so now let's import the
rest of the animations for idle jumping
standing melee and walking and now it'll
import all those and they'll be on the
right side so the amateur we have
amateur which is the tpos and if we just
give it a second
load load load there we go that took a
little second but now we can see we have
a bunch of animations so now all we have
to do is delete these guys we don't need
them and I'll show you why in a second
so now we have we're left with the
amateur now let's go to the animation
tab all the top
that's now this was a bug not a bug a
little uh error I had when I was doing
this my own sometimes the animations
don't show up now the reason is because
you haven't selected anything so make
sure your character amateur is selected
before looking at the animation to start
panicking okay so now here on the left
let's go to action editor let's now pick
a different animation so this is the
t-post so we can actually rename this to
T pose
now let's take a look at one of the
other ones and let's play it
this one looks like the idle animation
so let's rename it to idle and let's
just do repeat that for all the rest of
them so what is this one this one is
jump
so it's raining in that to jump
this one should be what
let's rename that to walk and lastly
this should just be attacked because
that's the last one okay so now on our
file now that we've renamed everything
we want to export this file as a gltf
okay so let's go to export and just do
that so GLT up there it is and uh orig
so now let's save it as a in our Dallas
file or wherever and we'll just name it
as our
character and now let's export
we'll export
and now we want to go to our project
and simply import this guy so let me
just open up my folder
whoops
so import the character that we just
exported and let me find it there it is
character.gbl glb
it'll import it and hopefully my editor
edits out me taking out my thing and
everything that would be nice
okay and so now when we open up this
character we can see that this has
popped up so let's take them our minion
and hide it for a second now remember
when we have a Gob an asset as a 3D all
we have to do is just drag it on right
so here we can see our character let's
drag it up a little bit and reset its
um transformation so let's do this so we
can reset it in the middle
and that's their character so he's
actually the same size too which is
quite nice or almost the same size and
now remember all we have to do is make
local okay now here's the best part this
comes with the animation player so now
we have animations for it we have attack
we have idle we can play it
yeah oh there we go
and now we can actually use this a
little bit so here we have our camera
and everything and it works quite nicely
now
what we can do so we have all these what
we can do is let's go into our script
and kind of play with this a little bit
so
I'm kind of assuming you know how to
read code but we'll go through this
anyways as together so in good go or in
3D there are three axes we have X Y in
the set now Y is the same as 2D so why
is the gravity Y is the the downward
Force right so this is adding gravity to
our character so if our character is not
on the floor we'll try to pull them
towards the floor now this is going to
be our jump so if we're on the floor and
I click spacebar then I'm just going to
jump I'm just going to make our velocity
equal to the jump velocity which is 4.5
in this case and all this is moving now
this isn't moving and this is
essentially idle if
if Direction means if my input Direction
input Direction Let's do one at a time
so input direction is actually a really
good way to take our three keys left
right up down and say hey which way are
we trying to go right so either we'll
end up getting a vector of 2D space so
we'll get a uh zero zero zero one zero
two or three uh one zero one one maybe
Etc right so 0 1 would be going to the
right I believe right so it would print
different things or zero negative one
would be left or up no down up I don't
remember it doesn't matter either way
this will give us a 2d Vector okay
and a direction is just this is just
going to basically take our input
Direction and as you can see it's just
going to make it a 3D vector or a vector
three because this guy is a 2d Vector we
don't want that we want a 3D Vector so
here we're going to transform our thing
our um Direction into
our introduction into a vector three and
so the y-axis is going to be zero
because well so you want to fly like
there's no reason to fly right so our y
direction is going to be zero
and then if Direction meaning if if
direction is anything other than zero if
if it's actually valid then will
actually move so this is going to be the
movement right it's a very simple
movement but it works and then this is
going to say okay if Direction isn't
happening then we're just going to move
towards zero with the uh attachment of
speed so we're going to go from our
current velocity to zero okay so what we
can do is we can actually go here and
say get node
character animation player dot play
idle
I think it's capitalized actually and
then we can also go here and say play
I think it was walk right
yeah it was walk okay cool and so now
when we play
we should have some animation hopefully
yeah there you go so there's our player
and so when I walk I start like
animating my player that's awesome
okay
all right so
um as I said for the rest of the series
I'm not going to be using the this
character so I'm just going to delete it
for now and I'm going to remove this
animation
but um I'm now going to show you guys
how to do the minion animation
here we're gonna ah make our character
invisible again and so just keep in mind
I have another video showing how to do
this but I'm going to show you how to do
it in this series anyways just so you
don't have to click off and then click
back onto this series so and it's going
to be relatively quick so all we have to
do is take our cake character animation
1.2 we're going to drag in our kkit
animated character I'm just going to
drag him in right under and now we see I
think his name is prototype Pete so now
again remember how do we make it local I
want you to pause the video and do this
yourself that you should we've done this
a few times so you should be able to do
this so on pause hopefully and we'll
make local
and so now here we see all the things
that we need and it's the same setup as
before so we even have the animation set
up for us so we have the role and all
that stuff however
this is a problem because we want the
skeleton to move not the type P right so
let's make him invisible for now and
let's zoom in a little bit so what can
we see well this is actually his
skeleton so if we go to the skeleton 3D
and make this invisible there goes the
the skeleton because so this is the
skeleton that we want to attach to our
player so if essentially if we attach
this player to the skeleton we'll be
able to move now maybe you think okay
well I can just do this well not really
it doesn't work right so maybe and then
maybe you're like oh okay well this is a
match so maybe I can do this right
now really again right so there's K
actually makes this really easy so he's
made bones for us so the bones are what
usually work with the skeletons so all
we have to do is let's attach bone
attachment 3D let's create it and we're
going to duplicate this a few times I
don't remember how exactly how many it
is but just a few and all we have to do
now is make up one bone for each of
these so body head arm left Etc et
cetera so let's start doing that let's
say a head
let's go into order so body after that
what's next
arm left
arm left now I don't think they have to
be capitalized I'm almost sure they're
not mainly because I'll show you in a
second
let's see a hand slot left
and a slot left
and Slot right okay so now if we read
the error it's going to say it's not
bound to any bond so we have to actually
start doing that so we have to bound it
to the head the head to the Head
and here if we actually okay so the body
let's look at the position of the body
if we attach it to the body it's going
to move okay maybe not that one let's do
the left arm
left it's going to move to the arm left
and same thing for the arm right it's
going to move to where the right arm is
and same thing with the hand slot it's
going to move to the like a hand slot
right it's the last one arm right
slot and now that's it so let's actually
take our node 3D now make sure you don't
delete the mesh we're going to delete
the
node 3D we don't need this when I take
our mesh outside here and first of all
we have to actually make sure that he's
centered again
in the middle there we go so make sure
the transform is zero zero zero zero and
now we're going to basically drag
everything into the bones so let's take
our head and Pop That Into the head
let's take our body drag that into the
body I'm going to take it on left drag
it into the arm
and an arm right so now let's minimize
all these delete prototype Pete we don't
need them anymore bye bye p and let's
play a Attack One For example and let's
put it and there we know there's our
attack that's awesome so we now have an
attack that works really nice
that's awesome so we now have an attack
so that's it that's it so we've
essentially animated our
um skeleton and so we could do the same
thing uh we're going to actually get
started in player State soon so
let's get right into
okay so the first thing we're going to
do
is I'm going to minimize everything so
make sure that you've minimize
everything so we have a more organized
player and for the camera let's just
reset all the transform and rotation and
let's go into our actual player and add
a node 3D
and then in our node 3D we're going to
add a spring arm 3D now this is a helper
node mostly used in three third person
cameras so this is perfect crew what we
need so let's take our camera and attach
it to the string arm now let's take our
node 3D and rename it to camera
controller
now this camera controller will
essentially allow us to control the
camera so let's add a script to it and
hopefully yeah it adds it to our player
uh folder and in here we're going to add
a function for input so this function is
going to detect any sort of input so
there's a built-in Guido function that
allows us to do that and it's called
input so let's just add input and let's
get rid of these comments and the ready
function we don't need that okay so
let's take our string arm and let's play
around with a few things and see what
happens so the first thing that we're
going to want to do and it will kind of
come back to why I did this later is I'm
going to take the spring arm and I'm
going to put it right above the player's
head so you can attach this right on top
of the player's head wherever player
you're using just put it above his head
not inside of his head we'll find out
later in a second why now let's see what
happens if I take our spring length and
just increase it now you see there's a
little line there that increases it now
the camera doesn't follow it however if
I play it should follow it so let's try
and see what happens
oh yeah there we go so that is the arm
essentially that is the spring length of
the arm so let's increase this and go
back to our game and as you can see it's
zoomed out essentially so this will kind
of act as our zoom in and out so it's
going to be a nice way to zoom in and
out now this isn't exactly how we're
going to do it yep but
um this is a basic idea of how it's
going to work so in our game we now see
that we have our that's all I want let's
uh make it a little longer so now in our
game we have our player now we want to
actually make our Mouse enter the game
now how do we do that well
I lied we're going to add in our ready
function again
an inner ready function we're going to
add this line of code
input.mouse mode equals input Mouse mode
captured now if we erase this and we say
mouse we'll see a bunch of different
things so we have confined captured
confined hibbling hidden and visible so
I think visible is the default that's
how we usually have it so once we want
to revert it back to having our Mouse
which we'll do later way later in the
series this is what we'll use if we want
to capture it and actually have it as an
FPS this is what we're going to use so
let's try it and play again and now our
Mouse should disappear so it's captured
our Mouse so that's not exactly what we
want to do because now we want to
actually have input so what we can do is
we can say if event is
input
input act event
mouse event in Mouse button
we want to do motion and so we're going
to check for the motion of the mouse now
if it is motion let's print motion and
see what we get so I want to see if it
actually works so if I move
if I click nothing hap should happen
only if I move my mouse because it's a
motion so here we have a lot of things
we have position and relative veracity
of a bunch of other stuff now what we
really want is the relative the relative
is what's going to allow us to
essentially if they if a vector 2 right
so we have two numbers here so X and Y
it's going to allow us to tell us okay
which way are we going in the Y and
x-axis right so on our screen in our
actual game we have a 3D scene but on
our screen when you see a 2d plane right
we see a flat plane in front of us right
because you know this isn't VR this is
just a regular 3D play now
and obviously if we just look with our
eyes let's say our eyes just have a 2d
plane that is how we perceive things so
we need to use that relative to
essentially move our camera around the
player
now let's say I'm moving to the right so
let's I want to stop moving the mouse
now I'm going to move my mouse to the
right and see let's see what we get
so now we can see that our numbers are
kind of increasing here right so it goes
uh it went from 1 4 14 right so or from
0 to 14 essentially so that is what
we're going to use to
essentially move our camera so
what we want to do
is let me copy this code this line it's
going to be a little long but
essentially we're going to make a
variable called The X rotation
let's import the sensitivity
I forgot to do that so we're going to
add a variable called sensitivity this
is just to allow us to change the
sensitivity of our Mouse later on so
we'll kind of have it as five for now so
for the X rotation this is going to be
the plane X plane right we're going to
want to rotate around the X plane now we
want to essentially rotate
take our rotation dot X subtract it from
the event.relative dot Y and then we're
going to divide it by a thousand times
sensitivity because that would give us
5000 because that's going to give us a
really big number and then we're going
to clamp it between these two numbers so
what is clamp well let's actually go
here so if you don't know how to do this
all we have to do is control and left
click
left click yeah and then click the value
or click the function it'll pop up the
documentation which is very useful so
clamp Loop essentially allows to give it
a value A Min and a Max and it'll take
that value and clamp it between those
two values so here let's say see this
one it's going to give we're going to
give it negative one and it's going to
clamp it between negative one and five
meaning it's going if it's too low if
it's past negative one then we're going
to put it at negative one right so if
it's negative 100 it's going to put a
negative one if it's negative a ten
thousand it's going to put a negative
one it doesn't matter right so it's
going to clamp it's going to make sure
that it only hits that minimum or that
maximum okay so we want to clamp it
between those two because well you'll
see in a minute
because there is a reason
either way we're going to do the exact
same thing now for the Y rotation but
we're not going to clamp it and you will
see why in a minute now what we're going
to do lastly is we're going to rotate
we're going to create take our rotation
and make it equal to Vector 3 x rotation
y rotation and zero now zero is the Z
axis we don't want to or we don't have
to move the z-axis right because we only
want to move this way essentially around
our character we don't want to move
under in a sense so let's play and see
what we get
and now when I move my mouse it moves
around the player now the x-axis the
reason we clap it is because I don't
want to keep it
going up and down so let's actually take
this out
yeah let's take this out for a second
and what we'll do is we'll copy this
and let's not clap it let's just take
rotation let's do the exact same thing
as the Y rotation
and do it like that will multiply it by
sensitivity and let's play again and see
what we get and now I get a really wanky
camera that rotates up and down right
because usually in a game we can rotate
all the way around on the y-axis meaning
we can rotate around him but we don't
want to have to be able to rotate above
a certain point that's why we clamp it
okay so that's why we're going to clamp
that value
let's delete that line make sure that we
don't get any errors and you can change
these values to whatever you want you
can try 0.5 these are the values that I
found the best you can change it to
whatever you want maybe you can try 0.3
and negative three whatever you want
right so it'll kind of depend later on
later on we'll add graph so you'll see
the reason why I chose those values Etc
so you can choose and play around with
those values and again you can also
change around play around with the
sensitivity you could always do that so
hopefully you understand how we rotate
it around the camera
okay the next thing is we're going to
handle Zoom now Zoom is going to be a
little different because the event is
not the exact same so we're going to say
if event is input
event
Mouse and button
then we're going to check which button
is so
the way I do this this isn't the best
but the way I figure out which event I'm
looking for so event is going to be any
sort of key or or input I give to the
key the computer so if I hit spacebar
actually it won't print anything because
we're only checking for Mouse button
okay so let's start clicking so if I
right click we can see that it prints on
the bottom now if I left click once
again now see here the button Index this
was right click this was left click now
let's see it should say
yeah button mask was essentially
buttoned down and then button mask 0 was
buttoned up so there's a bunch of
different things on how to
check for this now we're going to add an
if statement and this if statement is
going to basically allow us to see if
our input it's an index is going to be
Mouse uh the middle Mouse so if I scroll
down
it'll you'll see button index is equal
to five and I scroll up it should give
me oh
let's print the event outside that if
statement
let's play again
now if I scroll up it'll give me index
4. so now we can check if we're
scrolling up or down so by saying if
index input or button index is four or
five so this is scrolling down so let's
do something when we scroll down
we want to say
get node
springarm dot spring
length
looks like someone's at my door
ignore that for now
sorry about that okay so for our spring
length we're going to increase it by 0.1
every time I scroll I'm going to take
this copy it and we're going to add it
here and say negative
now let's see what we got
and now we can scroll in and out
now the reason the one of the reasons
there's another reason why let's
actually show you why so let's put this
inside of his head knee spring arm
and see what we're getting so they're
partly
ooh it doesn't look like it's happening
here so I had a lot of issues with the
camera rotation before if the spring on
was inside of his head it wouldn't
really work properly and so it would
kind of spring back into his head and it
kind of created a lot of bugs and I
found the only way to fix this and so of
course you could do that the only way to
fix this was to put it above his head so
if you're having bugs with it definitely
just put up above his head if you're not
go for it you can put it in his head
whatever you want play around with it so
let's go back to the camera rotation and
add a few things because it's not it's
working but it's not working perfectly
so
I've made it so that it's like this so
we're going to check if the spring
length is less than 10 then we'll keep
adding to it
now we're only going to subtract from it
if we're over 0.5 okay
we can actually change that to 0.1 if
we're not whatever you like so now this
will essentially max out at a certain
point so I can't zoom out too far and I
can't zoom in too close let's actually
do like two
I think that's a little far
okay let's see how far the app there you
go so you can Max and Min the zoo you
can make these values as well so let's
say
variable Max
Zoom equals
10 variable Min Zoom equals
true and then we'll replace those values
so here and Min Zoom
right there okay and that's it so now we
can zoom in and out pretty smoothly
and it follows the player so I think we
should be still able to move and yeah so
we can now move a little bit and zoom in
an hour of our player now the player
movement hasn't worked isn't working yet
but we'll get to that
but yeah that's our camera and it's
working pretty nicely now one of the
main issues later on is going to be the
global position because we're going to
need that now we'll get back to why we
need this later but for now I want you
to add this piece of code so we're going
to take our Global position of the
camera controller and we're going to
make it equal to the player Global
position because the camera controller
doesn't always follow the player
properly in the sense of the position
now the position will follow it but not
the global position so we want this to
kind of be separate from the player in
the sense that its Global Position will
change with the player okay let's get
started with our animation tree so
that's obviously first actually add our
animation tree and inside of our
animation tree let me just double check
which one we need yeah we're going to
learn about the state machine so this
steep machine is what we're going to use
the first thing we need to do is
activate it or can't activate it because
we need to assign it so let's assign our
animation player and then let's activate
it now we can see that nothing happens
because we need to actually add stuff so
let's add a few things and then I'll
explain what the state machine actually
does so first let's add the idle where
is that
it might be a little far so we might
have to just oh there it is never mind
so let's move that right there we can
kind of align it
now let's go from start let's take our
transition and let's drag it from start
to idle
okay now let's add one more We'll add a
few so let's add attack where is that
shoot attack one hand
I think that's all we really need is
attack combo you can add whatever you
want let's go to walk then lastly oh
I'll still jump
where's the shop animation
is there one yeah there is perfect okay
so if you're using another take it or
another thing you should have all those
animations let's play with this now so
now
you might notice a problem if you've
never used animation treat don't worry
we're going to explain it through it
mostly mostly four things now when you
play it
it works here however now let's try
playing something else so we see it's
already playing the idle now let's try
playing the jump it's not going to work
because our animation tree is
essentially overriding our animation
player now now let's try playing the job
that's what our jump looks like okay so
animation tree is going to override our
animation player because we have our
animations in here so now let's actually
organize this a little bit so let's have
our attack
I think we can zoom out nope I lied I
guess not
okay let's organize this by just
pointing that there let's put our walk
over here
and I'll put my jump on the bottom now
let's take our idle and we're going to
idle from walk to attack and to jump now
okay so let's explain what a state
machine is so a state machine is
essentially a machine that will allow us
to go and rotate between different
states now the state is essentially the
state of our player now if we want to
show the idle animation we'll be in the
idle State now if I wanted to show the
jump animation I'll be in the jump State
now if I want to be in the walk
animation jump State et cetera right or
walk State sorry so that's the idea now
now we think okay so how do I want to
get from it from Who attack well you
would think so let's say you don't want
your player to be able to go from jump
to attack well that means you don't have
to add a transition to that but I want
you to be able to get to attack from
idle and walk so what we can do is
attach one from both those so we can go
from either idle to it to attack or walk
to
now we want to be able to go from Attack
to idle or from Attack to walk right
because a player could or the in the
person playing the game could still have
their finger on W or pressing forward
right now we also want to go from idle
to jump and jump back to IO and we'll we
want to be able to go from jump to uh
walk to jaw let me double check that's
everything
and let me organize reorganize this
actually to how I have it on my
reference my attack is over here and my
walk is on top
and this is how I have it organized
okay awesome now let's change a few
things so first thing we're going to do
is on jump we're going to go through the
actual transition and you can see on the
right hand side we can actually change a
few things so we can change X fade time
now the X fade time is actually really
really cool it allows us to essentially
fade between these two animations and
blend them so if your animation player
that isn't smooth going from jump to
idle it'll actually smooth it out for us
so that's actually really cool so let's
go here and I usually do make this one
point one usually
yeah in my reference I did 0.1 obviously
it depends on the animation you might
want to double check whatever you're
using but that's usually a good
reference because it'll blend it out
even even though it's really fast now
for the switch mode this is immediate
right so there are a few different ones
I I'm not 100 sure what sync does I
think it just syncs the two together
immediate essentially will go from idle
to jump from idle to jump from jump to
aisle Etc and it while slay the actual
animation now at end will allow us to
play the animation and then go to idle
and then yeah so you can see that it's
going back and forth because this
transition is immediate right now
I think what do I want to do
we want to take this and we want to
take our mode and remove that
and let's go to walk this guy let's go
to our auto mode and take that off let's
go to this guy
and switch that off and that's it so now
we're going to be stuck in the Addle
mode now it'll only travel between these
states unless we ask it to so let's
actually go through all of them and turn
them all off now the only other one
we're going to switch at the end of the
animation is also the attack animation
so let's go to the switch mode and
change that to not end and then let's go
to auto actually this will be on auto
because
when we play in our game I want it to
automatically finish the attack
animation and go back to idle we don't
have to worry about switching it
manually now the other ones we're going
to have to worry about so let's turn off
auto for all of them
now if I didn't what would happen
especially for like idle to walk so
let's turn that back on and see what
happens
it'll go to a walk right it'll
automatically finish idle or actually I
don't think it'll even finish let's play
it
yep
wait
okay I don't think it finished it and it
just automatically goes to walk so we
have to make sure that that's disabled
and I forgot the transition from walk to
I'll so let's add that and make sure we
switch that off okay so that's our
animation tree all set up let's test it
a little bit let's go into our animation
player and let's add a few things so
the first thing we can do is we can
actually Auto load or load a few things
so
I'm going to Auto load these two things
and you're going to openly copy it so
we're gonna on ready variable animation
tree and we're going to get the
animation tree and then we're going to
also load the playback now the playback
is the animationtree dot get parameters
slash playback now this is it's not it's
hard to find here but it's essentially
parameters here we go parameters
playback here it is so it'll get this
entire playback as a node almost
and now what we can do is we can say
in Direction here let's say
way back
DOT travel
to idle nope that's when we're walking
so let's actually make that walk and
then what we can do here we can change
this to idle and now let's play
and now when I move or when I'm not
moving you can see he's idle and now
when I start moving it doesn't matter
what direction he starts walking
right which is really cool so now we can
travel between those two states because
we're manually doing it because the
travel is essentially towering our our
animation tree we're going to
automatically learn automatically we're
going to manually switch to walk and
then here if direction is zero
essentially and we're not moving we're
going to manually switch back to idle
right so let's say I switch to attack or
jump actually let's actually do that
let's go here
and go to
jump now this file worked properly
because
I'll explain why in a second let's just
try and see if it works
and let's jump and there you go so he
should play the job and go back to idle
automatically I don't have to travel to
the
to idle because it automatically goes at
the end of the animation right and there
we go so there's our cool little jump
now we'll add we'll make it smoother
later on and add different ways to do
this but let's add this back in and see
what happens it shouldn't work but if it
does that'd be kind of interesting okay
cool it doesn't work that's good well
it's not good because that's not really
what we want right but it's kind of
expected now why is that happening well
because what's happening is a physics
process the computer is going to read
this code in in this direction right
from top to bottom and it does this
every like second it does it more than
once a second right so it's going to
always be checking for this jump and
then it's going to go down and it's
going to be checking for this input now
if I do click input right if if
direction is valid meaning I am clicking
something then I'm going to be clicking
I'm going to go to walk now if I'm not
doing anything I'm going to go to idle
that means it's going to override this
now if I take idle out it should work
hopefully let's try it yeah so it should
it'll essentially go from walk or from
whatever it is to jump right because
it's not going for too idle what is
actually happening I believe is it'll be
going from walk to jump which is allowed
right because we have a transition there
so so this isn't the best way to do it
so we're going to actually delete this
and this is just a good way to
understand how it works next time will
be or in the next video
all right or in the next part we'll be
learning about
proper State machines and will actually
manually add in our own State machine to
essentially travel through the animation
tree as well so we'll have an a state
machine not only for the animations or
for the player as well so keep in mind a
state machine let's go over the
definition of a state machine again a
state machine is a machine with States
obviously that allow us to go in the
animation and specify which animation
we're playing at a time okay so one
state is Idle once it is walk now if
we're in the walk State we are going to
play the walk animation now keep in mind
this is an animation tree meaning it
only cares about the and the animation
state it doesn't care about the other
things right so we're going to manually
do that later on so hopefully
um you can stick around and we'll get
right into that okay so
we need to now change the way we walk
because
this anime this state or this velocity
is using this direction it just isn't
really working anymore so we're gonna
actually change it anyways to actually
fit our
um direction using our camera so let's
actually just do the interaction for now
and then we'll use the camera later to
kind of adjust our facing so first of
all let's just comment these two out
and what we're going to do is we're
going to say Direction equals and this
is actually very easy we're going to
make a vector 3.
three
a vector 3 vector and in this Vector
it's going to be a little long but hold
on with me so we're going to say
we're going to take our input get action
strength walk left and we're going to
say minus
the input walk right
okay now we're going to say 0 because on
our Direction on our y-axis we shouldn't
be moving right we're not jumping right
so the direction is only on the black
plane as if we're walking like on a flat
plane right now I want you to guess on
this z-axis what is it going to be it
should actually be very similar to this
but it's going to be the down and up
um inputs so let me just copy this real
quick
so in here we'll have the input get
action strength walk up minus the walk
down okay so essentially here what we're
going to have is why if if I'm clicking
left uh walk left right it's going to
say 1 minus zero which is going to be
one right so we'll end up with Vector
one zero zero now if I'm clicking
right I'll end up with negative one zero
zero and then on this one if I'm
clicking up I'll end up with 0 0 1 right
so try to visualize this in your head a
little bit but that's the basic idea and
now we can now let's play again and try
this
and let's see what we get so now our
bugginess is kind of gone it's not
jittering anymore because it's not
switching from it's not switching its
direction often anymore
okay
there we go and so we now switch from
the move state to the idle State now if
you can if you're noticing you can see
that the player is going from move state
to idle State really fast now this goes
back to what I was saying before so in
the animation tree we can actually take
the X fade time and make it 0.2 and same
thing for walking we can say 0.2 or 0.1
whichever one I like 0.1 but I'll do 0.2
to hopefully show the effect a bit more
so now when I walk it's gonna fade back
into the original animation it's not
going to be a cut it's a little smoother
now
okay awesome
in the next video we'll work on actually
getting our player to move in the
direction that our camera is facing okay
so last time we've implemented our
states and in this time in this part
we're going to actually do things in
that state in those States so for
example when we move I want to move
these things into our move State now
there's going to be a reason for this
because
now we can actually animate it in the
states so first let's actually move it
so this is going to be a little hard and
a little tricky because my reference
doesn't exactly have what we need
but we're going to figure it out
together so
here's what we're going to do we're
going to leave the direction here and
then we're going to take this
and copy it into our move state
but in here we're going to obviously
need a physics process and we're going
to say if Direction now we're going to
get a bunch of Errors now the main
reason is because first of all direction
is not here and even if it was it's not
the player so the first thing we're
going to do is we're going to say
variable player
and that's it whoops that's not what we
want to do
then we're going to say function
ready
and then we're going to say player
equal to get parent
now the parent of that this node or the
state is going to be this player is
going to be the player so so now what we
can do is say if layer dot direction if
player.velocity player dot whatever and
we're going to have to add this to each
thing so we're gonna have to say player
dot whatever player dot speed player dot
speed dot we gotta add a DOT
and Etc so hopefully that'll avoid all
our errors and this is basically going
to reference each thing so we're going
to change the player's velocity we're
going to change the players
um or we're going to reference the
player's velocity reference the player's
speed all these things okay
and now we should have no errors
okay and now what we need to do is we
need a way to change to the move state
so the first thing we're going to do is
we have to first check
okay so this is moving this is not
moving so this is actually this actually
belongs in the
idle state so here we would say Punk
physics process and then add this
so again it from the move State though
we need to do this so let's actually
copy this part into the idle state
there we go so now we're going to this
is the idle State meaning so if we're
not moving this is what we should be
doing so we're just changing our
velocity x and z to zero over the time
of speed so it's it's a very simple way
to do it um I think I change it later on
but for now this is good enough okay so
in our move state
um else here instead what we're going to
do is we're going to say player dot
change state to idle
right yeah okay perfect so now we need
two things
the first thing is let's actually add an
animation so here what we can do in our
ready function is we can say animation
Dot
travel
do
walk I think and actually what did we
name it let's see yeah walk
so here this is going to this is
remember the animation this is a bit
confusing because I kind of messed up
the naming a bit but the animation dot
is the playback because remember in our
change State setup we pass through the
playback so we're essentially saying
playback DOT travel okay so back to our
move state I'm going to say playback DOT
travel to walk now we can do the same
thing in our idle state but say dot or
travel to idle now this is actually a
really good way in the animation this is
a really good way to visualize what we
want to do so we want to be able to go
from idle to walk now in our idle State
we have to add something that allows us
to move or change to our to our move
State now what is that well we need to
add essentially an input check so in our
physics process what we can do is say if
input dot is action pressed now let's
actually do this real quick okay let's
add our own input so uh let's actually
avoid the error and say
lock right I think
I'm going to do is action pressed
actually not is action just pressed so
I'm going to do this and we're going to
say layer dot change state
to walk but first of all we don't have a
walk right so let's add all the things
that we need in our input map so let's
go to add new action add walk right
walk left
lock down
and walk up there we go
okay now here let's actually add
everything so let's do uh walk right is
probably not going to be that I don't
know why I did that hold on let me
delete that
walk right will be D walk left will be a
walking down we'll have it as s and then
walk up as w we can also do the regular
things
and do down has a physical key and then
walk left is left and walk right
and or key as walk right okay cool so
now we have the movement
okay so this is only walk right so what
we want to do is we actually want to
take this and say or walk
left
or
walk up
walk
yeah I think that's the last one okay so
now if I press anything it's going to go
back to change to change it's going to
change to the walk State okay so here we
have a way okay so let's let's restart
let's focus go back to the ready State
here let's take this out actually we're
going to automatically unready our
player is going to change states to idle
so we're going to go into the idle state
right so imagine this is this is a
really good way to visualize it this
isn't actually what's happening but it's
visualizing it for us so we're going to
start and we're going to go to the idle
State now in the idle State we can we
want to go to walk right so this little
transition here we want to be able to go
to walk now we have to code that walk
right we have to be able to change that
manually we we have to do it right and
to do that what we do is we check for
input uh wasd right and if we do then
we're going to change to walk now in the
walk State what do we want to do from
there well ideally we want to be able to
change back to idle if we're not moving
anymore now now player direction is a
really good way because
the direction is just going to be zero
if it's not right so if it's not if it
is zero it'll change back to idle so
this is a very good quick way and little
dirty way to change back to idle okay so
I think that is almost all we need in
there
let me just double check
yeah looks like that's it so let's give
it a try and see what happens let me
actually double check here
yeah let's give it a try and see what
happens
okay we got an error already nice what
have we got non-existent function
I might have um written something wrong
so we're gonna have to make sure we
see
in idle
that's why
let's move not walk okay
all right
and one more time we've had another
error in value index
direction if the player Direction
um let me double check
okay watch the error here invalid again
index Direction
character okay I think I see the problem
here we're gonna take the input
Direction instead
so let's go back to Player move State
we'll say input Direction Let's see if
that works
thank you okay nope
okay let's
do this together invalid get index input
Direction
okay sorry about that okay so we need to
make this Global in a sense so we need
to take this direction and put it
outside of the physics process so we'll
say we'll put it right here so variable
Direction and let's go back to our move
State and say Direction okay there we go
now that should work
and now when I move
it's very buggy but it should move
slightly
okay so what is happening well what's
happening is that it's always it's going
okay so what's happening is it's going
from idle to move and then it's going
from move from move state to idle State
now the reason is because of this so
let's take this out and see if that
works
okay
okay so the first thing we need to do is
actually loop our walk animation so
let's go to the walk animation
walk walk let's Loop that and play One
More Time
okay there we go we are now looping now
the direction movement is not actually
working but that's okay so this is not
working yet but we'll Implement that in
a second so
let's add back this guy the change State
and
we need to now change the way we walk
because
this anime this state or this velocity
is using this direction it just isn't
really working anymore so we're gonna
actually change it anyways to actually
fit our
um direction using our camera so let's
actually just do the interaction for now
and then we'll use the camera later to
kind of adjust our facing so first of
all let's just comment these two out
and what we're going to do is we're
going to say Direction equals and this
is actually very easy we're going to
make a vector three
effects or
three
a vector 3 vector and in this Vector
it's going to be a little long but hold
on with me so we're going to say
we're going to take our input get action
strength walk left we're going to say
minus
the input walk right
okay now we're going to say 0 because on
our Direction on our y-axis we shouldn't
be moving right we're not jumping right
so the direction is only on the black
plane as if we're walking like on a flat
plane right now I want you to guess on
this z-axis what is it going to be it
should actually be very similar to this
but it's going to be the down and up
um inputs so let me just copy this real
quick
so in here we'll have the input get
action strength walk up minus the walk
down okay so essentially here what we're
going to have is why if if I'm clicking
left walk left right it's going to say 1
minus 0 which is going to be one right
so we'll end up with Vector 1 0 0. now
if I'm clicking
right I'll end up with negative one zero
zero and then on this one if I'm
clicking up I'll end up with 0 0 1 right
so try to visualize this in your head a
little bit but that's the basic idea and
now we can now let's play again and try
this
and let's see what we get so now our
bugginess is kind of gone it's not
jittering anymore because it's not
switching from it's not switching its
direction often anymore
okay
there we go and so we now switch from
the move state to the idle State now if
you can if you're noticing you can see
that the player is going from move state
to idle State really fast now this goes
back to what I was saying before so in
the animation tree we can actually take
the X fade time and make it 0.2 and same
thing for walking we can say 0.2 or 0.1
whichever one I like 0.1 but I'll do 0.2
to hopefully show the effect a bit more
so now when I walk it's gonna fade back
into the original animation it's not
going to be a cut
it's a little smoother now
okay awesome
in the next video we'll work on actually
getting our player to move in the
direction that our camera is facing okay
so welcome back let's get right into it
and the first thing we're going to do is
we're going to jump back into these
states so we're going to want to
implement all the animation States now
now to do this firstly let's first
actually be able to rotate the player so
this is actually pretty simple and it's
about two lines of code so the first
thing we want to do okay all right it's
about to be four flags of code the first
thing we want to do is we want to be
able to turn our Direction into the
direction that our camera is facing now
to do this we're going to need
a variable called H rotation so
right above the
we need right here so let's put it right
here so we'll say variable H rotation or
Road
we will get the camera controller so we
can say
you just drag it in and say camera
controller
I'm going to get
we're going to say transform
dot basis
dot get
Euler
hopefully it fixes Euler I think it's
like that dot y okay so what is this
let's take a look let's go to camera
controller
let's actually go to our camera I think
or will it be here
I think it'll be in our camera we search
up the Euler
won't be there okay
here we go sorry there it is so rotation
edit mode Euler so this will return us a
vector three and we're going to
transform it into a 2d scene or um we're
not going to transform into a 2dc we're
going to use that as a direction okay
and the transform is generally the
transform and the basis is
it's not here but it's the basis of our
node so it's going to help us actually
get the direction of the node
okay or the direction that the camera is
facing okay so now
what we can do is we're going to say
Direction
equals Direction
and rotate it so in order to take our
Direction with the current input we're
going to have to take our input and then
rotate it based on its previous input
direction right so let's say if
direction is Vector zero zero zero we're
not going to do anything to it because
it won't matter right now however if we
have like one zero zero then we want to
actually rotate it so to do that there's
a function in good o that helps us do
that pretty easily
it's just dot rotated and we're going to
rotate it on the vectors 3 up and H
rotation and then we're going to
normalize it
formalized
this will allow it to just be a better
cleaner number so that Godot doesn't get
uh jittery okay next up in our move
state
this is a little
line of code I'm going to just copy it
here and I'll explain it so here instead
of the player we're not going to rotate
the player I had a lot of issues
rotating the player so instead we're
going to rotate the mesh and this works
pretty fine mainly because it doesn't
matter if the player itself is rotated
or if the mesh is rotated because either
way the player will move in the
direction of the mesh so we're going to
rotate the mesh rotation we're going to
lerp it to the angle that
is currently our Direction okay so we're
going to take its current rotation and
then
turn it to this whoops
this direction
okay and then we're going to do it at
this speed so you can increase the speed
if you would like but this is the speed
I found was kind of good and smooth okay
so lastly let's make sure we have the
mesh loaded which we don't so let's do
that
so we're going to load the mesh by
adding it right here
I'm going to say on ready variable
player mesh equals get node Warrior okay
okay not Warrior we're gonna do
um
this guy
whoops
and
like that okay so we want to load the
node 3D you might think we'd have to
load the skeleton or something else but
now we're just going to load the node 3D
kit so let's play and see what we get
and now when I move
it's completely flipped so let's
actually what's happening is our camera
is flipped so let's
flip the character actually
rotation we'll say 180 okay there we go
let's try one more time
nope that's not what we want to do I
think we rotate the player itself so
let's go to the transform here we'll
rotate the layer
or we can end up rotating one of the
children I think nope okay let's rotate
this guy
there we go okay so let's rotate let's
keep that zero and rotate the animated
character instead so now when I try to
move and look
when I press w
it'll go in the wrong direction now
because I rotate it differently but
you'll now see that the player rotates
properly
and everything's reversed so we'll fix
that in a second but
the player now if I click W the player
will now go backwards in the direction
that my camera is facing so what we can
do is we can actually just go here and
we can say
let's double check to see if the right
and left are also reverse let's see
write is also reversed okay so what we
can do is we can just reverse these and
put this one
behind here
and then make sure we get that negative
and then reverse this one as well so if
you're having any problems with this
this is one option I think there's
another option which I wouldn't really
recommend it would be to just reverse
the polarities of the direction Itself
by saying negative Direction but I
wouldn't recommend that
all right so it's kind of working
but the animations are still wrong sorry
about that we're gonna not we're not
going to change the input
um so we're going to keep it as it was
so walk left minus walk right and walk
up minus walk down instead of the
instead of rotating the K kit animating
character I'm going to keep that at zero
same thing here we're going to keep the
rotation at zero and instead we're going
to rotate the spring arm either 180 or
one negative 80. they're they're pretty
much the same so make sure to rotate the
spring arm if you're having the issue
where the player is facing the wrong
direction and now we have the player
moving in the correct direction
so now when I go forward and press W
it'll
correct itself and do that awesome so
now let's continue on in the jump State
because I think that's the only thing we
haven't done so let's actually take this
out and say pass instead of printing
something every time so to go to the
jump State because we don't even have a
way to do that yet we have to actually
be able to go there so in our animation
tree here we see there's two different
ways to go to a jump state from idle and
walk so let's do idle first so in our
idle State we're going to essentially
add an input check right and this is
really easy so
let's actually add our input so let's go
here and add a new action called jump
and while we're at it let's just add
another one called attack
with two T's and not three
and jump we'll say spacebar
and then attack we'll say Zed
all right let's close this
and now we'll say if input is action
just pressed I think we can do just
press that's fine and then jump
and
right player is on floor
then we'll jump now we go back to our
main character and we see here that this
is pretty much the same thing we have
here because we have to make sure that
we check if we're on the floor so let's
copy this and delete this let's delete
the handle thing as well so here
let's say player dot change
state to jump
okay because here we don't have to jump
because we're going to handle the
jumping in here right so now in our jump
State let me just open up my reference
for the jump state
so let's add a ready function so
function
ready let's pass for now let's add a
physics process function and then in
this physics project process
we'll add a few things in our ready
function first of all let's add our
player so let's say variable player
so we have access to our player and then
in our physics process we're going to
add a new code or a new piece of code
that's going to allow us to jump but
it's going to be a little different than
what we had before I'm just going to be
moved towards so instead of setting the
velocity we're going to add it add to it
over our process function so we're going
to say move towards so we're going to
take our current player velocity I'm
going to move it towards the jump
velocity
instead of just setting it equal to it
and then we're going to go to the speed
of this negative divided by 50. you can
set a certain number if you want but I
found this is pretty nice because you
can if you edit the jump velocity this
it will kind of switch the speed it goes
to as well so let's say you don't like
the jump velocity let's say JUMP
velocity of 4.5 is too little and you
change it to seven this will adjust
itself and jump at the same speed or a
similar speed
okay now we want to be able to switch
back to idle because inner jump State we
have to we've moved to jump state but we
have to be able to go back to jump State
as well so this is actually really easy
to say if player is on lore
then we say player dot change
date
I don't now why does this work well
because in our jump State it's going to
be constantly checking if our player is
on the floor or not right because the
only time we're in the jump state is if
we're jumping right and so once we've
jumped we want to just check if we're in
the auto state or not and that's it so
I think that should work so let's take a
look and see if it works let's try
let's jump and nothing's happening okay
so silly I realized that the jump
velocity uh 4.5 was too small and um we
now needed a bigger one so there we go
there's our jump it was working fine
um we just need to increase the number
of the jump velocity so I did 200 we
could do maybe like 300 let's see what
we get so it should be a little higher
yeah there we go so now it's a much
smoother jump okay so in our jump State
there's one last thing we're going to do
let's remove the print state
I like to add a animations uh function
so I'll say jump and um and then here in
this function we'll say player
what is it
I don't want to mess this up so yeah we
just say animation.travel to jump
and here we go okay so let's see what we
get let's play again and if I jump
play the animation jump why is that do
we have the animation jump we do
travel to jump
let's see player oh I actually want to
call that function that's probably why
that'll probably help us actually play
okay let's try that
there we go
okay there's our jump now the reason I
have the await okay hopefully
you didn't see that the reason I have
that is because as you see in the game
it's not very smooth right it doesn't
really jump the moment I jump like the
animation and the jump itself are not in
sync so the what what I did is I just
await 0.1 seconds so we say a way to get
treat dot get timer point one dot
timeout now if you don't know what a
weight does it's pretty much just gonna
tell our code okay we're gonna wait this
amount of seconds before continuing now
this amount of seconds can be anything
it doesn't have to be a timer sometimes
it can wait for something else like a
signal right
for example if our animation played in
animation frame so
um I know animation tree doesn't have
that but let's say I said player
animation player changed that could be a
signal as well right but for here we
want a timer so let's test this and see
0.1 seconds is enough
it's not so let's see let me show you
the way I did this and know where the
timer would be so first of all we have
to turn off animation tree
and we're going to zoom in and we're
going to go to animation player and
we're going to go to our jump we're
going to go through it slowly we're
going to see where he actually starts
jumping it's about 0.4 to 0.5 So at
around we're going to wait around 0.4
seconds
and let's see what we get so let's
actually make her tree active again
let's see what we got
and there we go now he looks a lot
smoother and actually jumps when the
player is supposed to jump and now all
we have to do is we can say in our idle
State we'll copy this and we'll go to
move State and we'll just add this right
here into our physics process and now
when I play
I can move and jump while I am moving
there we go and remember in our
animation tree there's no way to go from
jump to walk now if you want to you can
do that but I'm not really sure I guess
you could you could check for the
velocity so if you wanted to go from
jump to walk which it doesn't really
matter because what's happening after
the jump it'll go back to idle and if
you're in movement or if you're moving
in idle it'll go to walk right away but
if you want to go from jump to walk
directly all you would have to do is go
into your jump state and instead of just
checking for is on floor you can also
check you can say
uh I'll just write pseudo code so I'll
say if
um player velocity
velocity
and not equal zero then change to idle
or etc etc so that's a good way to check
if you're moving or not okay so but I'm
not going to do that so if you would
like to do that go for it okay last
thing before we change to the next part
is Let's Make a way to go to the attack
state so let's go to our attack State
let's copy these because when I need
these you can go into our tax data and
add this so I'm going to say attack anim
and we'll travel to attack
one h
under capitalized there we go and we'll
copy this okay
and now let's
yeah let's add a physics process so
let's say physics process function it'll
pass for now we're not going to add a
way to move back but in our idle state
what we can do is we can copy this and
then say
attack uh attack and then we're going to
check for the attack button and now
let's see if this works so from idle to
attack
and there we go he moves to the attack
State now we can't do anything again
because well you know there's nothing
going from the attack State back to idle
so let's add something real quick
in our attack State I want you to think
of a way to
how can we go from Attack to idle how
can we check for that okay
okay so in our attack State there are
probably good some ways to do it we
could do a weight we could do whatever
but the way I did this was a little
simpler what I did was in our animation
tree instead I just selected the
animation finished
connected to our player and then in here
I just check if the animation that
finished was the anime it was attack so
I say if Adam name is equal to attack
right then we'll change to idle now
that's one way to do it another way to
do it is to manually uh connect the
signal to the animation tree I don't
usually like doing that so I I'm pretty
lazy and I like to do this instead but
that is also an option so in our text it
you could manually select or manually
connect the node and check for this
signal a weight could work as well but
I'm not going to do that so
yeah let's do that
okay so let's play and see what we got
let's attack
and nothing happened I think the reason
might have to actually be
okay it's not looped
let's go to Let's debug this little bit
because I remember there were some
issues I had with this so let's print uh
it's not going to be attack it's going
to be Attack One h
okay one h
okay hopefully that should work okay
we'll have to restart
and now I should be able to move again
so attack
and attack
attack and we can move okay now one
problem you might notice so in our move
State let's go to our idle now let's say
I want to attack while I'm moving that's
great so let's copy it
and that should be it right however
there is a problem so let's move attack
while I'm moving so while I'm in the
move State and I attack I'm going to
keep moving because my velocity is set
right and I'm not setting it again in my
attack state so this is actually a
pretty easy fix what I do is I just set
the velocities to zero on ready so here
I'll set them both to zero and that's it
there's no reason to
do anything else because once it's set
to zero in the attack State this is
going to go back to idle and an idle
state it also has nothing it says or it
moves also to zero but if I'm ever
moving again then it'll reset it back to
whatever I want it to be moved to so now
when I'm moving I'll stop moving and
attack
okay there we are
so those are those are that's our states
welcome back so let's get right into the
tile map so first off let's close the
player we don't need that for now and
here let's go back to our main world we
have our regular static body floor but
and it's nice and all but we want to
make the scene a little prettier so
let's um create a new scene
I'm going to create a 3D scene I'm gonna
name it
Library
I'm going to add a static body
tick body
we're going to add a collision shape to
it
and obviously we're going to want to
probably add a collision shape to it so
let's just add a regular uh
square box and let's go into our
files and look for some assets so we'll
look through this together so we have a
lot of banners
we have let's look for flooring so we
have barrier which is cool
corner
so we can actually just look up floor
hopefully
Okay cool so we have floor we have for
uh dirt
there's a lot of cool stuff
um let's look for something there isn't
really anything outdoorsy but that's
okay let's look for
wood large no we don't want a large
decorated nope
let's actually get the tile that one
looks nice so let's take a tile not Arch
it's a floor tile
and that should bring us up the
tiles
so let's look for this one there we go
okay so let's take the floor tile small
and use this as our regular floor plane
so let's put that up here and now we can
do is put the static body inside of this
nope actually sorry I lied we're going
to make this local
and we're going to take the mesh out and
we're going to delete the new 3D and
then we're going to drag the static body
into the mesh now let's turn on smart
snap
let's reset the position and just move
it downwards like that and now let's
take this guy and move him right there
and now let's go back to our Collision
shape we want to turn off Smart snap
we're going to move this down
to hit the square
just so that it's the same size as the
flooring
and then let's expand it
to match the floor itself
and hopefully try to just match it as
best as we can if we go a little outside
it's okay because we're going to be
duplicating this anyways okay let's save
this in our main scene
let's look to maybe add a few other
things
um what else will we have we'll have
small broken Maybe
you can kind of just go through it and
add whatever you want I'll add this one
so let's duplicate this and say
lortile
decorated
I might add some a few
you know what we can do actually
I think should just be able to
where'd it go
yeah no we can't do that we'll take the
decorated wool office in here
right here like that and then pop the
static body delete this delete this
and now we need to move the static body
as well so let's actually take our
snap though and reset it
there we go so now it's smart snapped
okay
now we have to make sure that this is a
pixel perfect so that's why we turn on
smart snap so that it snaps for us if we
look at the position it's going to be at
three zero one which is pretty much
perfect and now what we can do is we're
going to go to the top left scene we're
going to go export as mesh library and
this is basically going to create a mesh
library from our scene okay so let's
export it and we can say merge with
existing but there isn't one anyways so
this is okay we'll say library
now if we close this file
we should be able to see library.tress
now if we double click it it'll bring us
these two things in items
now in here it has the built-in static
body so it has collisions which is
really nice so let's double click
Library again and it also has the mesh
library that we have or the mesh that we
added into it okay
all right so now what we can do is let's
make this invisible for now and then add
a tile map
nope not a time up a grid map sorry
a 3D tile map essentially now what we
can do is just drag in our library into
the mesh library and there we go so now
I have a floor tiring and now we can
just drag and draw our floor now this is
pretty tiring so what we can actually do
to make this easier is to hold shift
click and drag and then Ctrl F to fill
and then we can kind of just put the
decorated
or tirings randomly Maybe
a little bit of uh decoration okay and
now let's play and see if it Glides
awesome it collides and we don't go
through the floor so if you didn't add
the static body you would most likely go
through the floor let me actually delete
this to make sure that it's not just
that and it's invisible it's actually
the floor okay cool
there we go we have a little nicer
flooring and off video I will probably
add a few other things like walls and
whatever so um I would suggest you go
through the tile map or the grid map
that we have and do that on your own
I'll probably make the scene just a bit
prettier and I'll probably show you what
I added but I'm not going to do it right
now so
um
one two three
okay so let's get right into it
um this is the scene that I've made
um basically it has three layers as you
might want to call it we have floor
walls and Mists so here I've just
created a new library full of miscs and
this is the live this is the scene I've
made so if you want to download this
I'll probably leave the final product as
a GitHub link so you'll have access to
this in the end but for now I want you
to be creative and create your own scene
okay so let's actually add some life to
the game so
we're going to be adding a
uh torch so let's create a torch light
and if you're using another asset pack
or something else we'll be using um you
can use whatever you want maybe a
um something fire related so in my case
I'm going to be using a torch I'm going
to probably yeah I'm going to use the
mounted one so let's
basically do this let's drag it in make
it local and then we'll right click the
torch and make scene root
and then we'll just delete the node 3D
or you could have just dragged it into
the scene instead of making it a 3D
scene but uh whatever don't worry about
it so let's just adjust this so that
it's kind of
right there
let's look at the transform see where
it's at
I think we can set that to zero and that
to zero
or not let's set it to negative
something okay and let's just move this
up a little bit
to be flat it doesn't really matter
because we'll adjust it in the main
scene anyways but I just try to keep it
somewhat centered okay so let's save
this as perch and let's create a new
folder called
objects
and then in this folder we'll just save
the torch and in here we're now going to
learn about
particles let me just rename this to
torch and so now we're going to learn
about particles this is going to be kind
of fun because there's quite a bit to
this so let's add a
particle thing so we're going to search
up particles and we are going to use the
GPU particles
so as you can see there's quite a few
but we're going to be using the GPU ones
so I think the main difference between
these two is that this uses CPU and this
uses GPU so let's add this
now for the oh what did I click okay
that's just the mesh okay so for this
we're going to need a few things so
we're going to need
um some
surface area things now for that I'm
going to add it probably to a Google doc
folder or either get you to download the
beginner
GitHub link so definitely check that out
and you're going to need to download
those so I'll be right back and download
them myself all right so let's get right
into it now that we have the two um
things that we need we have fire.tress
and these smoke frames whoops I don't
want to add that in we're going to get
started right away so for the amount uh
we'll leave it at as eight for now and
then play with that later the next thing
we're going to do is for the time we're
going to change this to 0.5
or the randomness we're going to change
that to one
now if you're wondering what I'm doing
um basically these are just a bunch of
settings to help me draw fire now the
hard part is teaching this because a lot
of this was just kind of guess and check
um when I made to when I came to do this
myself so
um you're if you're looking to change
this or make your own it's going to be
really hard because you just need to
kind of guess and check as well unless
you're really smart and I don't know how
to do that without guessing and checking
so
okay
so let's um in the process material we
make a new particle process material and
let me just bring up my reference and we
have quite a few things to change the
first one is we're going to a mission
shape and we're going to create it into
your surface we're going to go to the
direction
right here we're going to change that to
25.
and we're going to change this to 1 and
this to 0. so this is going to make it
go upwards
and the gravity we're going to change
that to zero
because we don't want it to go back down
we just wanted to
they're all wood up essentially and then
have it keep going up so for the initial
velocity and for the angular velocity
we're going to set the relax velocity
Max to 7 and the velocity Max here to
70.
and then for the angle let's close these
for the angle we're going to change that
to 360.
well 3 is 60 and for the scale
I think the scale is something I did for
the actual scale but let's not worry too
much about that okay
um scale
I added a curve so texture curve and in
this curve we're going to click this and
we're going to just add a point by
dragging this down and then clicking
I think we can
do I add here we go add point and we're
just going to drag this up and we want
it to go straight up about here and then
back down to about 0.5 so it should be
somewhat like that don't worry if the
numbers aren't exact that's the general
idea
so that's the curve let's close the
scale now for the color the color is
where we're going to use the fire truss
I believe so here
we can we should be able to just drag it
in
I think if we do that
nope
gradient
[Music]
ah here we go we drag that in there and
then in the gradient you should be able
to drag that in here as well there we go
okay so that's the default fire color so
yeah let me redo that so you can
hopefully get that so for color wrap and
initial ramp we're going to create a new
gradient click it and then we say
gradient and we're just going to drag
our fire color into it you could
alternatively I think just there's some
things you could copy I'm not 100 sure
but it's a lot easier to just do this so
let's do that for both of them so fire
here we go
and now
I think that's no we're almost done now
we go to animation and we're going to
switch the max speed and offset Max I
believe to one for both of them and
that's it for the process material now
for the draw pass we're going to I
believe let me just double check so I
don't say something wrong we have the
quad mesh in our material we're going to
create a new standard material 3D we're
going to open it and we're going to go
down to Albedo there's a few things
we're going to change but Albedo is the
first one and we just drag in the smoke
for the texture
and then we're going to go to vertex
color and use on our as Albedo or Albedo
however you want to say it we're going
to go to shading and we're going to say
unshaded
and we're going to go to transparency
and say depth free pass and then add
and
then we're going to go to
billboard and say mode article billboard
now we have some particles coming up
minimize everything and now we have our
particles so this doesn't look like fire
but what we can do now is we can go to
the amount and increase it by a lot
and now we'll have this
so 20 000 is actually a lot what I used
was about seven thousand I used this now
we see that it's really big so what we
can do is we can actually scale it down
all right so after playing with it a
bunch the best solution that I found
unfortunately is just to just scale it
down to 0.1 so it'll look a lot
different from this but that's okay I'm
also going to be using local coordinate
so if it's not I don't think it matters
actually I think local coordinate is
something else so don't worry too much
about that
and the drawing pass let me go over it
one more time
the size of the actual thing I'm going
to actually change that to let's try 0.3
okay that actually works a little better
nice okay so we'll do 0.3 and then point
one for the scale of the actual thing
and
I think that's it everything else should
stay the same
so for the pass one make sure we change
that to 0.3 we can maybe even try point
two
oh yeah that's actually a lot better so
let's try point two
um you could even try point one I
thought I tried that but it didn't seem
to work okay well it seems to work now
so I guess we'll do point one and now
when I play and I put it in my scene
we get this cool little fire effect
which is awesome
um now
let's stop the play and make sure you
add the torch to your world we can add
it here we can say
um objects
and then we'll add the torch here and
then what I can do is not do that I can
move the actual torch instead so let's
move the torch here and let's put it on
the wall so let's bring it up a little
bit
a little small so let's
scale it
and
which side is the wall mount I think
it's 90 degrees so it's or 180 so that's
180 it and put it on the wall
right there let's put it up a little bit
okay there we go so now we put it up
there
uh actually let's put it down a little
bit let's put it right under that
okay
we'll put it yeah that looks good okay
so let's put it there
and next now we're going to work on
environment or next coming up we're
going to work on in on the environment
stuff so let's get right into that as
you already know we have already created
a kind of environment mainly for the sky
so first off let's save this as its own
environment scene and so how you the way
you can do that is by going to this
arrow and saying uh save and it's a mine
is already saved and but a thing should
pop up and allow you to save it and I
have mine right here so let's actually
create a new folder for it and say
folder uh not folder in Via little or
mints and let's put all our environments
in there
and where is it here we go so let's put
our environment in there
let's go in
okay there we go and now what we can do
is reset this and so now we have a
really dark gloomy scene which is kind
of doo doo but that's okay now what
we're going to do is add a new
environment and in here put the
background will add a custom color it'll
be black and now this scene looks like
this but when I play
what we get is pretty much a really dark
scene now the reason you there is light
is because in my character I've added a
omnilite so add a node called omniola in
fact actually let's just delete this no
highlight let's keep it let's keep the
characters on the light and let's play
and we should get this so it's a really
dark gloomy
um scene and if you're wondering how to
kind of get the scene a little better
what we can do is just make this a
little bigger we can reduce that a
little bit
and here the light is on top of the head
if you want you can just move it around
wherever you want this doesn't really
help very much what I did was I just put
it on top of his head like that and if I
play again sometimes it gets a little
buggy
now it looks like this now it's not
shiny too much but you can still see the
scene
and there's our little light so there's
our little torch however the torch isn't
giving much so why don't we add a light
to it so if we actually search up the
light we have a few different things we
have directional light omni light and
Spotlight now this is pretty good for
what we want so let's try this
let's increase this or let's take that
rotate it we'll why don't we
actually we'll use omnilite for this
let's do omnilite
but the omnilite let's leave it like
that let's play and that's pretty much
all we should be a have to do and now we
have a little light let's actually move
it so that it's centered around the
light
the torch in the middle there we go and
now when we play it's disappeared so
let's replay it and if I move away
there's my torch and it has light and
everything so that's really cool and so
you can duplicate them and add a bunch
so let's actually do that real quick so
what I can do is I can just let's turn
on smart snap and control D and then
I'll just move a few down
and let's move
this one over here and then add another
one right here
and then let's take the second torch and
move that down a little bit
in the first torch and move it down even
more okay so let's play and now we'll
have a bunch of torches in a row awesome
so we have a cool little torch effect
okay so for the environment what we can
do is we can save this as the dungeon
theme so let's save this in our
environments and
I believe that's kind of it one thing
that I like that you can try is adding
volumetric fog
we can add that late
and this is what we got
so it's a pretty cool environment fog
effect
and it's really up to you if you want to
increase the density and play around
with it you can do whatever you would
like but this is something I found
really cool so
that's it
so I just um added a fog and
I changed the light color to this it's
just a little darker than what it
usually is so now the final result looks
like this so I just wanted to let you
guys know in case that's something you
wanted to do for yourself instead of
volumetric fog I decided to use fog so
that's it for the environment let's
close this and for the player let's now
add in our weapon so when we attack he
is actually attacking using a weapon but
he doesn't hold anything so it doesn't
really look like he is so what we'll do
is to his right hand slot we're going to
add an area 2D or a 3D sorry and then in
here we're going to add two things a
kill Vision shape and for the Collision
shape it'll be look like it'll look like
that
we'll just make it like that and move it
up a little bit and then let's add in
the sword so let's actually just search
up sword and we have two different types
uh we have we have a bunch of stuff we
have uh a shield I guess
sword shield that's not really what we
want let's add in we want this one or do
we want this one
what's the difference Actually I don't
even
they're pretty much the same one it's
just a bit more broken okay uh that's
not what I meant to do
okay let's use this one so for this we
have to drag this into the area 2D we'll
make it local
and we're going to drag out the mesh
because that's all we need so let's
delete that and what we'll do is we'll
just reset the transform for everything
and now we have this but it's reversed
so let's just flip it
flip it um 180 which is awesome so
actually let's do this manually so 180.
the z180
and then the rotation we'll move this up
a little bit and the rotation for the X
actually want to change it to 90.
nope the Y yeah there we go so now it
looks like it's upwards okay and now it
looks like it's holding it which is
awesome so I believe let's
let's do two things so
first I want to add something to the
attack State this will allow us to
control the speed that the animation
player goes at so in our attack State
let's go to our scripts go to the attack
State and in the physics process we're
going to add this piece of code
player.getnode.getanimation tree because
remember animation is actually the
playback not the animation tree so we
have to get the animation tree we're
going to say Advance Delta times one now
this should actually make it really fast
so let's see
okay that's actually the default I think
so let's uh increase that number play
again and see what we get okay so that's
really fast so now so now let's decrease
it by 0.1 or 2.1 and now we should get a
super slow attack
okay that's our really slow attack very
cool
that's a really slow
nice attack but there it is so there
that's a really slow attack now in order
to see if the area 3D is actually
following it what we can do is we can
actually go here and go to visible
Collision shape and we can play
and let's see if the Collision follows
up okay it does awesome so now we see
the Collision it follows the sword which
is really cool because that's really
that's actually really accurate right so
now we can actually see all the
collisions around us and let's turn that
off because it kind of looks ugly and
Okay so
there's one thing I want to add in case
you're not if you haven't used the K kit
and you're using some other and uh thing
I'm going to add a piece of line that's
going to help you
um figure out some things in terms of
transformation
this is what I use so self dot transform
this is specifically for the um here
actually let me just pull up my
reference here so this is specifically
for this guy this model so here we have
the area 2D
um this sword and I had to adjust it so
that it fits the sword in game and
obviously it doesn't look like it does
but in game it does and for the area 3D
I had to basically set its transform to
constantly follow the sword so in order
to find the sword what we had to do
was printed the there were things that
we had to do here so we have to print
the uh get parent get parent find bones
so we have to go to the skeleton and
find this bone and print it and that
will print us the number 58 because here
each one of these has its own ID unique
ID so it has a number right so each of
these bones has a unique number and then
so ignore this one we don't actually
need that one and then here I would just
say get the global position of where it
is right of that bone which I think was
the right hand
yeah right arm I don't really remember I
think it was right hand or right arm one
of those two and I don't know serve
joint that's the one and then I just set
the transform of the area 3D to that so
if you're having troubles
um getting the area 3D to follow because
you're using some other sort of thing
this will help you a lot and in the
future if you ever use something else
this will help you a lot okay
ignore that then okay so if you're using
the K kit we don't need this so let's
actually remove this and we'll leave the
script because it's uh we'll use it
later so let's actually delete all these
and Save
and that's it okay so
um let's get into creating an AI the
first thing we have to do is create a
new node we're going to create a
kinematic no not kinematic I keep
forgetting that they change it we're
going to create a character body 3D
and here we're going to go to Collision
shape where is it uh Collision Collision
shape if I can spell it right there we
go and we're just going to add a sphere
and then what we're going to do is I'm
going to be using the
you know what
let's actually do this let's
um well first of all let's save this
into here
and we'll do
um monsters we'll save in here we'll
save it as
Skelly
and this guy will be the default
skeleton so it should do that what we
can do is
we can let's actually do this so we can
go to player we can drag this in let's
make it local
and drag in the K kit
and then minimize this and delete the
rest we don't need this and this doesn't
affect the player because we made it
local okay so now we have our character
with the animations with everything we
need and we even have the okay
what's perfect actually is let's
actually increase this or bring that up
a little bit and what's perfect about
this is that the sword is there too so
that's actually really nice let's
minimize all this and we're going to be
using the sword in a minute so let's not
worry too much about that
okay let's minimize that
and let's rename this to
Skelly and we now need to add a few
things so in order to for this to work
we have to add
um
let me just get my reference we need to
add a few areas where it will detect the
player so the first area because this is
a melee we need one we need one area
that it will detect the player to walk
towards unless of course you don't want
it unless you want it to always be
walking towards the player we want it to
be conditional walk so we want it to
have States essentially right so this
will have States in theory but we won't
use the script States so what we'll do
is we'll have
will have an idle State we'll have a
move State and an attack state so those
three states now those states that we do
will not be
script wise and they will it will not be
animation tree wise we'll simplify this
as simple as possible it's not going to
be very complex but it's going to be a
nice AI that that just chases the player
that goes from idle it chases the player
walks towards them and then attacks him
and if he leaves the attack area it'll
start chasing again and if it leaves the
if the player moves the uh chase state
or chase area it'll start to go into
idle State again so we need to add two
areas area 3DS
and we need to duplicate this and we'll
rename this one to attack player
and then this one will be Chase player
so let's add collisions to these
let's duplicate this and I can just pop
that in and let's create them as a
sphere
so this one will be the attack so we'll
actually keep it around that big we'll
move it up a little bit we'll take this
one same thing sphere and then we'll
make this one a lot bigger because this
one is going to be the area where it
chases the player okay so let's take
these two and lock them and let's just
make them invisible because we don't
need to see them right now okay
next up we have to add a script to this
so let's build have a built-in script
and let's do a template uh we'll do DEET
node default we'll create and delete all
these and then let's go to attack player
and just connect everything so we're
going to do the area entered
no body entered sorry and then Chase
player when your body entered and then
attack player we'll do body exited
and then Chase player I'm going to do
body exit it okay so we have Chase exit
and end body at Chase player X enter and
then vice versa for the attack okay so
there's a few variables we're going to
need in order to keep track of what's
Happening
so first of all we're going to add the
speed and jump okay we don't need jump
velocity we just need speed so let's
have its speed this will be the speed
that the thing goes at and then these
two variables will be
will help us keep track of things so C
player will happen if we can chase it
okay so what we can do is say c
layer equals true
right now if he exits we can say C
player equals false right so this will
help us keep track of what's happening
and then we can also do that for the
attack right so we can say here we'll
say it's true if we enter that area and
then if it exits that area we'll say
yeah false now in order to keep this
super accurate Well what we'll do is
or the exit will also add
sorry attack is equal to True here and
then attack is equal to false here but
here we'll also say if it exits well
most likely that means we're going to
see players equal to true and if it
enters
we'll say C player is equal to false
Okay so
make sure you understand what's going on
here essentially what we're doing is if
we enter the area where we can attack I
want to say okay we're going to attack
the player but we're not going to chase
him so this is actually Chase player
should probably change it let me do that
right now actually say Ctrl R say Chase
player and replace them all
here we go so if you do control R we've
we can just replace everything easily so
we have Trace player and attack player
so if we are in the enter in the area of
attack we don't have to attack chase him
we only have to attack okay if we're in
the if we enter the chase state it
doesn't matter if we're in the attack
state or not because at that point we're
just going to chase either way and then
if we
exit the attack state or attack area we
want to start chasing the player again
and not attack him okay awesome now this
is kind of important because now the
problem is body entered can include the
floor
now we don't want it to chase the player
if we're looking at the floor right we
only wanted to check if that body is the
player so what we can do is say if body
Dot
name
or what we can say actually is
player
as oh no in body
dot name this one's actually a little
less bug prone especially in the future
with things that we might want to add
now however we have to make sure that is
Cap case sensitive so we'll capitalize
this and now we can do this for each of
these so just copy it over to everything
and just make sure we end it and
everything properly
and that's it so now we're checking for
the player in the body dot name okay all
right next up we need to
add a few things into our physics
process so first of all let's add a few
different things
so let's take let's Auto load the mesh
the um we'll just say mesh and for the
node we'll say get
this guy
and it'll be K and make sure that we say
get node properly
oh my gosh
well there we go okay so we get the
character we Auto load the mesh
I'm going to add gravity and we're going
to hold a direction globally there's a
reason for that later on and then lastly
um it's different
and we'll also add Health why not we'll
add that right now so we'll give the pla
the Monster Health right now okay so
let's add our physics process function
so we'll say physics process
and in here what we want to do
is we want to first get access to our
player so we'll say variable
layer is equal to
get node
and then get it now how do we get it
that's a great question so it depends on
where our player is and where our
monster is so generally in order to keep
this like bug prone what I do is I'll
add a 3D uh
let's add a node a 3D node and let's
duplicate this and what we'll do is
we'll say player
let's add this here so we can actually
name it player
and then we'll name this
um
let's actually rename this to characters
and then this to monsters
okay so here what we want to do is we
want to take our monster and add it into
this folder so we'll just pop it in and
we'll put it there so there's our
monster let's see if it's on the floor
properly
should be let's just drag them up a
little bit okay so there's our skeleton
now from here we want to be able to get
the player so how can we do that well
here we can just drag it which is nice
but let's understand this so This dot
dot dot slash means get get parent so
we're going to go up one parent we're
going to go up another parent Two Worlds
and then we're going to go down to
characters and then down to player right
so we get parent twice go to characters
and then player so okay let's just
remove that and then add that so now we
have access to our player now we want to
see if player is valid so if player is
valid what we'll do is we're gonna we're
just gonna get the players the direction
of the player we're going to out see
where the direction is right so we want
to find out where it is by just saying
player.position minus our own position
and normalize it and that'll give us the
direction of the player
now
what we can say now is say if C player
no chase player I changed it
if Chase player is true what we can do
[Music]
is we can first
we can move towards it by doing this
by saying velocity.x and Dot Z is equal
direction
Etc et cetera so this is pretty much the
exact same thing for moving the player
right and that's pretty much it now in
order to make sure that this actually
kind of works we can say if Direction
then we can move if direction is not
valid then we'll we'll actually move if
it isn't like if we can't find the
player or for some reason the player
doesn't
um have a position proper or whatever
then we won't move towards it but if it
is then we will move towards it okay
now
we also want to check if we're attacking
so it will say here
if Chase player L if attack player so
we'll say attack player
if attack player is true then we want to
attack so it to attack what we'll do is
we'll just set our velocity to zero
because we don't want to be moving as
we're attacking so we'll set our
velocity to zero and then what we can do
is let's actually load one more thing
that I didn't actually do in my
reference we'll say on ready variable NM
equals get node and we'll load our
animation player so let's go here
and load the animation player
and then here we can say if attack
player is true we'll say lay the
attack I think it's one H let me double
check the we have to double check the
way it's spelled okay perfect and
else
I believe it's idle so let's say NM dot
lay
idle right so let's make sure it's
spelled correctly okay just case Capital
now let's also add this to here and say
run
now what's happening here so first of
all we're checking to see if Chase
player is true if it is we're going to
check for the direction and then we're
going to run towards it right so that's
what this is now if if attack player is
true right we're going to attack and set
the velocity to zero now we also want to
set the velocity to zero if we're idle
okay now this is not the best attack
State format because and there is
actually a better way match might
actually work a little better but I'm
just gonna do it like this for now
okay but basically we have three
different states we have run attack and
idle and it's not the best way because
this this only works because we have so
few if we have more States and more
attack patterns and stuff like that we
don't want to do this because this will
overwhelm us very quickly but for now
this works fine for the
um Direction one other thing we can do
is move the mesh towards our player by
adding this and this is the exact same
thing that we use for rotating the
player however let me just make sure we
switch the player mesh with mesh so
replace all
so this is the remember when we used the
rotation for the player this is pretty
much the same thing but we're going to
rotate it towards the player Okay so
direction.x
okay so now let's actually also do this
for the attack so let's go here oops and
say
[Music]
and
here I actually also check for if
Direction in the attack or the mesh
rotation because sometimes it would
error mainly when the player dies but
that's okay so we'll leave if Direction
mesh dot rotation okay
and that should be it that should
actually work
oh we probably want to ungravity that'll
probably be a good idea so we actually
fall to the ground so let's add gravity
if not is floor velocity dot gravity
and then we also actually want to reset
the direction every time we go through
the physics process
and I believe that is it no that's not
it because we want to move and slide
newest freaking something
okay so moving slide will actually help
us move okay so let's play and see what
we get so all right there's our little
monster over there let's see what
happens if I get in range
ah he's attacking
and he's moving towards our Direction
and if I get in range it'll start
attacking us
yeah
okay so it works nicely so let's add a
few things
um first of all we want to add
um health so we want to make sure that
the health actually works so what we can
do here
is we can check for if the health is is
less than or equal to zero so we can say
if health is less than or equal to zero
then we will
yet no we don't have to get node we
already loaded it we'll say animation
dot play
yeah I don't know if that's what it is I
haven't seen it yet so let's go over
here and look the feed okay there it is
defeat
so that's the defeat animation let's
actually see what it looks like let's go
to defeat and let's play it ah there he
goes okay now we play the defeat now we
want to connect the animation finished
and add it here so here what we'll do is
we're going to play the death animation
and then what we can say is we'll check
to see if we play the death animation or
not death but defeat in this case and if
we did then we'll just cue free after so
that way we don't have to Q3 the moment
he dies we'll play the animation and
then we'll die okay
this first of all he's not going to die
because we haven't added a way for him
to die so in our area 3D for our player
let's go to the area 3D that we added
for the sword now we have to connect a
we have to connect a body entered
here
oh that's not where I wanted to add it
okay hold on let's delete this go back
to our node let's disconnect this and
connect it on self that's where we want
to do it we'll say if monster in body
dot name
then we'll say body DOT health minus
equals five
and now what we'll want to do is
probably just add the word monster to
this guy so we'll say monster Skelly and
then we'll also do it here because it
doesn't save automatically and then we
can play and we should be able to kill
him so let's uh go do that let's go kill
him
why is my kinda playing animations
interesting I think I might have
yeah there it is it's not active okay
whoa what is happening
oh I was messing around with the brawl
animation let's delete that okay
let's attack kill him
and it's not working why is that
okay let's go to our skeleton and print
the health let's see what's happening
let's debug this together a little bit
we might have to just reload because we
changed some things and it was kind of
messing with the game so let's try one
more time and hopefully this works so
let's go to him attack
oh yeah he should be dead Okay so yeah
there we go so the reason why it's not
playing I I kind of knew this would
happen is because it's playing and then
it's going into this and it's it's
playing trying to play whatever is here
right so it's trying to play this but
it's also trying to play this because
the health is low so what we have to do
is we have to add an await function and
say a weight dot anim animation finished
and that's it so this will allow us to
stop the code not a stop but await until
this animation is finished but
fortunately enough for us it's it won't
really matter once it is done because
once it is done we're gonna keep free
anyways so let's play and see what we
get
okay
let's go to him and kill him
come here skeleton die ah there you go
and he died and that's it so
let's take out that print function that
we added so we don't spam our debugger
okay
now I think that is it for the
um attack or the uh AI we're going to
add some more stuff later so to prep
that what we'll do is we'll actually add
the death function and then for the
death function we're just going to pass
for now we're going to add some
inventories and weapon drops later so
we're going to add that in and we'll do
that here so I'm definitely
add that in and we'll get to it later
once we do
okay that's it okay let's get started
into our inventory system so the first
thing we're going to need to do is
create a global script to actually be
able to hold our inventory so let's
create a new folder and call it global
and in here
we're going to have two things we're
going to make well two scripts or so
let's create a new script and call this
um
game
and then let's open that to duplicate it
and call it in that'll be our inventory
and wait for it to scan okay cool and
now let's go to Project settings on the
top left open this up go to auto load
and let's load up our two scripts so
let's add in game first and then add in
inventory there we go
let's close it and that's it well so
that's it that's how you Auto load a
script okay so now let's open these and
start adding things to it
okay so in our game what we'll have is
I'm going to put these three things
these aren't really related to the
inventory but we're going to need them
uh later on anyways so let's add them in
there let's close everything all these
scripts on the left so that we have a
bit more organized thing
and now let me just open up my reference
okay let's open up the inventory and
we're going to have
a variable called items and we're going
to have it as a dictionary
now okay what is a dictionary so a
dictionary is very similar to an array
it's basically
think of a
think of a large train each train has
carts in them and each cart has people
in them or things so this is essentially
a train so each
we have in a dictionary we have
something called keys and then we have
the value of that key so essentially
what it will look like is we'll have the
name of a key so let's say
[Music]
um
it doesn't have to be a string so we're
going to have yeah okay I'll give you an
example so let's say uh name
and then the name of that object will
have it as a string so this will be
um
we should probably look uh let's say
staff
okay so this is a key and this is the
value so the value is a string called
staff and the key is a string called
name now the way we're going to do this
the way we're going to organize this
inventory well first of all these are
the items that we have and that exist in
the actual game so these aren't the
items that we hold but the items that
just exist period okay so the way we're
going to organize this is we're going to
organize it using numbers so each number
will will signify a single item so first
we'll start with zero so zero will be
the first item that we have
and that's a key so the key 0 signifies
one dictionary another dictionary inside
so we have the Outsource side dictionary
and then we have another dictionary
inside that dictionary okay and now we
can start storing information inside
that so this is an item so this is One
Singular item inside of a bunch of
different items so the way we can show
that is by having a comma and then we
can just space
do one
so we have one item here and another
item here now if we go to the K kit
skeletons let's look at the assets there
should be
it's not an arrow yeah that's an arrow
okay we'll use an arrow why not we'll
say
name Arrow
and then
yeah that's it for that now let's I'm
going to add a few other things so I'm
going to add
description I'm going to say desk and
this will be an empty string
and then so make sure that we have
commas on each line first of all
and then the next line
will have cost of the item
so these are just some default things
that I usually use in my games for
information on items so you just want as
much well not as much but you want all
the information about your item in here
so let's put type
and lastly we have icon this one is
pretty important and we will reload
an aw image but we don't have one right
now so what we'll do is I'll just drag
this in
okay now let's fill this in a little bit
so staff we say the type is a weapon the
cost we can say 100 description this is
a staff
and then let's copy all this
put it in here and then let's change it
up so
we'll say this is a green arrow this is
a green arrow
the cost we'll do 10 uh we can say misc
for the type and then for the icon we'll
leave it as that for now I will look for
some
I think I already linked it in the
beginning but uh if you've already
downloaded but I haven't downloaded it
yet so I'll I will do that in the next
part so let's finish setting up the
inventory this one is a little easier
because all we have to do is create an
empty dictionary so what that looks like
it's just inventory
that's it that is our MP inventory and
so what we'll end up doing later on is
if we want to add an item to our
inventory all we have to do is refer to
it and say okay let's take an item from
our items and add it into our inventory
so in fact what we can do is create a
function for this
so let's do that let's create a function
that says that is
add item
and then we'll say variable has item
equals false
ah hold on
I forgot count
okay
count
no that's in the inventory okay account
we don't need it here actually because
okay so in our inventory
the inventory structure will look like
this sorry about that so it'll be all
this but with the whoops with the count
so in here we will also have a counter
to see how many of this item we have so
that's how our game is going to work so
don't worry about this I'm going to
delete this
but just keep in mind that we will have
the key count in our inventories so here
in our when we add a item we want to see
if we have that item already so the way
we can do that
is by having a variable called has item
and then what we'll do is we'll for Loop
through our inventory so we'll say 4i in
inventory so it'll just for Loop through
the inventory with each key and then if
I if I check the
let me add a few spaces here if I say if
inventory I at name
is equal to the item name
then that means we already have it now
where is the item name coming from well
we have to actually pass that through
the add item so now we can add items
using a specific name of something so I
can add green arrow for example right
and then what we can do is check if we
already have a green arrow in our in our
inventory now if we do this is actually
pretty easy what we can do is just say
inventory at I at count plus equals one
and that's it because it should already
be loaded and count would be like let's
say one we'll just add one to it instead
of adding another one into it and then
we'll say has item is true now the
reason we do that is because now outside
of that for Loop we will
check to see if ha if has item is false
that means we don't have the item in our
inventory now if we don't we what we
want to do
is first we want to get access to the
item that we're that we're adding so we
have to get it inside our items
dictionary so first we're following
through the items and we'll find the
item that we are looking for and that's
easy it's the same thing as this but in
items so we'll say if items at I add to
the name is equal to the item name then
we found our item that we need okay so
all we have to do is copy that over so
we're going to create so
unfortunately Godot is a little hard or
not good though dictionaries in general
are they are a bit tricky to add to so
in order to add to a dictionary we can't
just say plus equals we have to copy it
over and then add to it so in order to
add to it we have to basically set it
equal to it so
the way this the way what this looks
like is
first of all we're going to say
um temp items equals items so in the
items let's say I want to add staff
right let's say I want to add staff to
our inventory and we don't have it so
we're here right so we add it here but
to do that we need to add the count to
it so to add to the temporary dictionary
we're just going to say we're going to
say temp dick count
plus equals one and this adds to our
dictionary so this is as if I'm the
coder I'm the pro on the computer I'm
gonna do this I'm going to say okay
count
plus one or is one okay so that's how we
add to a dictionary so it's not very
intuitive right so we set it equal to
one
okay so now what we do is we say
inventory at inventory size equals
attempt dictionary so this Advantage
essentially allows us to add it at the
end of our dictionary so if our
inventory has things in it already let's
say it has one object it'll add it or is
uh at Key zero it'll add it at Point at
Key one okay and that's it so um that's
how we add to our items so now what we
can do
is let's create a
ready function to test this out a little
bit so we can say ready
oh what did I do here
um
control Z
items okay
um that's spacebar here function
ready and we'll say add item
staff and then we'll print
the
inventory and then we'll also print it
before we added it
just to see what we have Okay so let's
print it and see what we get
or play and see what we got okay so here
we go so here we've printed the
inventory before so we have nothing in
there and now after we added the staff
we've added in our item and see here we
can see
um zero name staff description cost type
icon and the count
and that's awesome so let's try adding
this twice let's see what happens it
should do the same thing but it'll have
count two
there we go it works it works awesome
perfectly fine okay so now that that's
tested and done
um I will
lastly actually let's uh no actually did
I add it here yeah I know I did okay so
um that's it for the inventory I'm going
to find some icons import them and if I
didn't already link it
um I will make sure to link them okay
okay
next up we're going to get into the UI
of our inventory so the UI is going to
be in the 2D scene so it's going to be
on top of our 3D but it's going to be 2D
so the way we do this is let's create a
canvas layer so this will essentially be
on top of our screen and it'll just be a
simple 2D canvas layer scene that we can
add to our game so I also added an
inventory folder
um with the icons that I've imported so
I'll show you the icons I actually need
to fix them
because these are going to be the icons
we use so probably use something like
the staff and whatever but one of the
problems is that it is in a big like big
thing like this and I need to disconnect
them so I'll probably do that if you
want to download everything
um the way I do it I'll leave everything
um hopefully leave everything you need
in a Google Docs folder at the end of
the course and there'll be a
GitHub link that you can probably
download from so either you can do it
yourself and and put all of these in its
own file or just download it from what I
do so
here let's rename this to UI let's save
it and we probably want to rename it
actually to the UI I just reflexively
saved it
and now we're going to create the UI for
this so
the UI for a inventory generally
speaking
it it kind of depends on what you have
and what you want but we'll make it like
very simple so I'm going to have a panel
and this is going to be our background
so it's actually turn on the grid so the
grid is this guy and this is smart snap
so we're just going to turn on the grid
so we can see a little better
so let's just do this
and create a UI for it so I'm just going
to create it so that it's in the boxes
here and that's it that's going to be
our background for our inventory so
let's actually
um
take this and what we'll do is we're
going to
lock this
and we'll name it
BG and then we're actually going to add
a node 2D
doesn't really matter actually we can
just do controller it doesn't really
matter and then this is going to contain
our inventory so let's rename this to
inventory
and then let's also add an animation
player
that's an animation tree don't want to
do that I want an animation player there
we go and then we're going to have in
here in our inventory we're going to
have a grid container
that's going to hold our slots for our
inventory and then we're going to have a
button
for our close button
um you know what
yeah sure we'll we'll implement it I'll
show you how to implement that
um so let's rename this to close let's
rename this to
in the container
and then we're also going to have a
label
which is going to be our title
title and then let's go to the
where is it theme overrides on the
bottom I'm going to go to font size and
just increase it and let's actually
write something so inventory as we can
see that's really big so let's make it a
lot smaller and just move that in the
middle and maybe let's do
80 that sounds good okay now that's a
little big let's do 70. okay there we go
so let's actually drag this out over
here like this
and then what we can do watch this magic
that good will do for us we'll say
horizontal
and Center we'll Center everything and
we'll also turn on auto wrap
um the reason why I like to turn on auto
wrap for everything is usually this I I
feel like this would rarely happen and
it's more common in Android
but the reason why this is good is
because okay if I have a bunch of words
it'll automatically put it to the next
line instead of going that way to the
right so
if your screen resizes on a phone let's
say you have a computer screen and then
your phone resizes it instead of the
words going off the screen it'll smart
snap it and put it where it thinks it
should go kind of right so it'll go to
the next line so yeah so auto wrap is
really useful okay next up we're going
to go to our UI let's add a script
and a default script awesome
and then in here we're going to add a
signal from here pressed here we go we
now have the Press signal
we'll delete that and lastly we're going
to actually have our animation player
work so let's add two different
animations so we'll have trans
in I'll say Trends in like this
and then
Brands
ouch
and then from there let me just double
check a reference we're going to rename
the animation player anime
and
now for the
what we'll do is in the transition out
what we can do is say from here we're
going to take our inventory we're going
to go to our
layout transform position and we're
going to key that
and then we're going to key that first
position and now what we want it to do
is slowly transition into a position
where it is let's say 3 000 pixels away
okay that's kind of far let's say
1000 that's fine
actually we'll do
six
50. we want a nice number okay so now
it'll look like this
so you can get it to transition out
however you want but I'm just going to
get it to go down now transition in what
we'll do
is we'll go from the top to the bottom
so we'll say
negative
350 650.
and then we will go to one second we'll
reset this and key that
okay so now it'll look like this and
then our transition out will look like
this so it goes in order okay so in our
UI what we'll do
we're gonna do two things
we're going to firstly
we're going to say let's actually load
our animation tree so that's our
animation so we'll say NM equals
get node
NM
there we go and now what we can do in
here on press closed we can say what is
that I have to say variable that would
probably be a good idea right
in here it will say NM dot play
trans out
now what's cool about this is we can
actually add another function called
input
yeah and then say
okay so we're gonna have to actually add
this we are going to say if event is
action press inventory then we will play
the animation Trans in
but
um
we have to add this so we have to
actually add this key because it doesn't
exist so let's go to Project settings
and add it to our input map
let's add it and let's create it as e
H you could do I as well if you want but
I'm going to do e for now okay so let's
test that and see what we get so there's
only one way to transition in and out
right now so let's see if those two work
hello idle actually end up in front of
us actually it won't end up anywhere
because I haven't even added it to the
scene so let's actually go back to our
world
first of all
let's go to our player let's add in here
hopefully that should work
uh it didn't add
I'm gonna have to okay there we go
okay um what I'm gonna do actually is in
our animation uh let's go to reset and
have this like that
and let's have it at negative 950. so
that'll be our default reset and it'll
always reset on uh screenplay so every
time I launch the game it'll reset to
this Okay so
we used to launch the game
wait for it to load and I press e and
our inventory pops up and that's it now
there's a few problems obviously I can't
click the button because my mouse is
stuck so uh we have to do first here
when I click the inventory I have to
make sure that my mouse mode is visible
so let's do that
now another thing we want to do is we
should probably want to pause the tree
so let's actually do that as well let's
go here
and say get tree dot pause is true
now we should be able to transition this
in have our Mouse and then unpause now
we can't unpause because we have or we
should be able to unpause so let's
actually make this false now there is a
problem this is a very very common
problem I try to point out every video I
make not every video but it's really
common whenever you pause a scene you
have to make sure if you have a UI you
take the process function or the process
mode and set it to always or whatever
works I I usually do always because
always is a good way to make sure it
always works so let's play and see what
we get
so we're in our game
if it loads
yeah the game is loading all slower now
okay so we are in our game we press e
and our game pause so I can no longer
move and I can click the close button
and we're back in and it lags quite a
bit but that's okay but our Mouse needs
to go back in so what we can do is say
I think my computer is just being a
little laggy right now it's not the game
hopefully
okay
and that should work um I'm not going to
test it actually uh because it's my
computer is being a little slow poopy
right now so
um I'm going to close that and you're
just gonna have to trust me it works or
you're gonna have to test it yourself so
that is it we'll add a few things on the
next part but for now this is how we do
our inventory UI
okay
so the first thing we're going to do in
our inventory is we have to explore the
concepts of how we're actually going to
build this and step by step we're going
to build it from the ground up so so far
we have our inventory as a script and we
have it all in variables and this
technically works right and that's
that's it our inventory is technically
speaking done right we even have a
function where we can add an item
however the main problem comes from
interacting with our inventory and the
UI of our inventory now this is where
most people struggle the concept of an
inventory system
is actually not very difficult it is the
concept of interacting with that
inventory through the game that is where
most people struggle so we're going to
build this from the ground up one step
at a time so the first thing we're going
to do is we're going to go into our
inventory container I'm going to drag
this down to the bottom and let's move
this over here
like this
and so the first thing we're going to do
is actually fill our inventory with
slots so obviously as hopefully you
might know most inventories have slots
in them right so we have a slot uh let's
say 30 slots or 28 slots and each slot
contains an item so let's do that so
let's go into our inventory or actually
we'll just make it from here so
let me just pull up my reference
so the first thing we're going to do is
make the slot now the way you design the
slot doesn't really matter okay so I'll
I'll do how I you might do it or how I
would usually do it which is I will have
a panel or some sort of background and
that will be the first node that will be
the parent node and then I'll have a
Sprite
and then I will have a label
and this label is actually going to be
our count label
this is usually exclusive to whether or
not you actually have
uh stacking in your game but it depends
on what you want so again the structure
of your slot doesn't really matter it
just depends on how you want it and how
you want your sauce to be so let's save
this a slot scene and our inventory so
let's save it and let's now rename this
to slot and add a script
now this is where the magic happens so
this is where we'll be adding everything
that we need to interact with a slot so
the first thing we're going to do is
we're going to create a bunch of
variables that are going to help us
interact with this now let me I'm just
going to copy paste it and I'll explain
each one as we go along so first we have
all the these things so these are
basically going to allow us to contain
an item inside the slot it's going to be
a local slot variable almost okay now
the item name is just an item name
description cost count type right so
these are all the things that we
actually described in our inventory
right so everything will have every item
will have these things including
the count that we put out over here when
we add it into our inventory right so in
our
slot we also have has item is equal to
false now this is just going to be a
Boolean that allows us to check if our
slot has a item and we'll explore why we
do that later and we also have a Boolean
that says Mouse entered now the reason
we have this is actually because we're
going to not yet actually but we're
going to be checking if so
hopefully we already know this but I'll
explain this concept anyways most so in
our node system
if I uh show everything so in our 2D
canvas items uh usually it's 2D we have
2D node 2D and control so let's look at
control nodes and scroll down a little
bit here we have all these children as
the the control is apparent of all these
children right so we have panel Tabor
Etc right now what does that actually
mean in good dough when something is
apparent of something the child will
usually inherit all the properties of
the apparent so the parent which is the
control node
is a parent of the slot of the panel
sorry so that means we have the signals
here on the right that are ingrained
from from control so we can see it has
says control now this is actually really
useful because we now have Focus entered
we have GUI input and we have Mouse
entered and mouse exited now this is
actually really useful because now we
can just connect this and we also can
connect the mouse exited
and in these we can now
say mouse if Mouse exited
we'll say mouse entered is equal to
false and if Mouse
entered we can say true now for the
mouse entered we only have to make sure
it's true if we even have an item so we
can actually check if has item is true
uh
we can do that or you could have just
said without the true but I always like
to have the true because it kind of it's
one of my habits uh mainly just so I can
understand when I read it and know if
I'm checking for it to be true or false
okay
the next thing we're going to do is we
want to only show the Sprite so let's
actually rename this to Icon so this
will be our item icon okay
so
in our item icon will only show it if we
actually have an item so what we can do
is say
if has item is true then we can say get
the item icon and
uh show it right whoops and if not then
we'll say
icon dot hide okay now we'll also do
this for the count so we'll we won't
show the count unless
it has item is true okay now we can do
the same thing here and hide it if as
item is false and that is it
um now if we do have item what we'll do
is we'll update the count every
millisecond so here we'll just say
we'll actually remove that
I'll say
count here we go text is equal to string
item count now the reason we have string
here is because item count is a integer
okay so an integer is a number right
even if we had float so if it was like
this that's also a flip now this is a
problem because text is a string right
so here in our scene here this is a
string right so even though I type 0
that's still a string it's technically
like this
right so we have to convert it to a
um
what you call it uh string right so this
will allow us to convert this integer
into a string right and now we can now
actually check
for input so we could do there is a
signal here that says GUI input I don't
like it it's a little limited so I tend
to just use the input event now the
reason you could try to make this work
without all this and
using using GUI input but I honestly I I
think this is a little faster and a bit
more it makes a bit more sense so
where's the indent let's pass for now
if you can hear the sirens outside but
there's Sirens right outside my door
okay so now what we can do is check for
left click now we have to actually add
this because we haven't added I don't
believe so let's go to our project
settings go to info map and add left
click
and down in left click we will add the
mouse button
left Mouse button is this one I think it
is yeah so we'll add that
and now when we left click on a thing we
should actually be able to do something
so let's print something for now so
we'll say uh let's print the item name
item name
and then
let's actually make this work so let's
go into our input or our UI for
inventory now you might be wondering
okay how do I fill this in well do I
just drag it in like this and then
duplicate it or duplicated Munch and now
we have this well yes and no so okay
first of all let's actually change the
inventory container to make sure that
everything gets sized properly so
let me just find my reference here
um
for the whoops no we have to do it in
these slots so in our slot what we'll do
is we'll go to layout and we'll go to
custom minimum size let me check what I
have is the minimum size I think it's
64. yeah usually 64 by 64 is the minimum
size so we'll move this down a little
bit
and in our UI we now have this so in our
inventory container we'll actually
change the columns to six and now we'll
have a proper grid and now what we can
also do if you'd like we can go to theme
overrides constants and separate
everything manually so we can do five
and five or we can do
10 and 10. so now we can separate each
of these slots as much as we like okay
now let's actually fill our inventory
the proper way and the way that most
people do it okay because manually doing
this doesn't really work very well so
what we'll do is we'll delete all these
and we'll add a script to it called
inventory container and what we'll do is
we're going to make a function called
fill inventory slots
now this inventory slots will allow us
to up it'll do a few things first of all
it'll up it'll fill our Container full
of slots and it'll update our slots with
the proper item that is in every slot so
we have to do that okay so the first
thing we have to do
is we have to make two variables
one where we preload the the slots let's
actually rename this to slot
so let's preload our slot that we just
made hopefully that's the right
okay it wasn't the right path and then
we're going to also create an inventory
size now this is going to be whatever
you want I just did 24 because I would
like 24 slots now the way I usually
calculate this is if I have six columns
6 times 4 is 4 rows so we'll have six
columns and four rows okay so 24 is a
good number or 6 times 5 is 30 so I try
to go by a whole number so that way it
is organized and we don't have like five
slots in one row and then two slots in
another row it looks kind of weird right
so we try to organize it quite nicely
okay
so the first thing we're going to do is
we're going to for Loop through our
inventory size so we're going to say for
Loop and in inverse size okay now in
each eye we now fill one slot or we we
add a slot so
I mixed up a little bit sorry we have to
actually
add every all these slots in our ready
function not our
fill inventory so let's actually add
already inventory or ready function and
for here let's pass for now and here we
can actually just copy this
and do that instead now this is a lot
easier all we have to do is say
uh variable item temp or we'll say slot
temp
and then slot
instantiate and then add the child uh
slot temp and this will do it 24 times
okay and then we will also call this
function right after so this will
actually allow us to fill these slots
with the information and then this will
allow us to add these slots sorry about
that mix up I just
was mixing up my words a little bit so
now when I play I actually will just
have my inventory slots now when I click
on a slot it should print the item name
now it didn't print anything because I
don't have anything in the item name so
let's actually go over here and say
default and let's replay the game and
see what we should get
now if I enter a slot it should print
default a bunch of times now this is a
problem because what's happening is that
this is going to happen a bunch of times
and I haven't even checked for Mouse
entered now if you you don't have to
count but I'm going to tell you this
printed default 24 times why because
what happened is it didn't check for the
mouse entered it just printed 24 times
because we have 24 slots and we we
didn't check for if the mouse is on a
specific slot so each of these slots
have its own custom unique ID to control
and so Mouse Android will work really
nicely now however input will not work
very nicely and because each slot so if
I have two slots open and I'm checking
for both of them
then it's not going to work because yeah
like it's just going to print 24 times
hopefully you understand why this is
happening and now what we can do
is in our slot we'll just say
if Mouse entered then we'll print the
item in so let's replay and hopefully it
should only print one time so let's go
to our inventory play or click
oh why is it not working
let's double check
okay I think what we actually need to do
we might need to
change some settings
let me double check in our UI
selection exchange okay let's replay and
hopefully this should work
um
okay let's debug this
and let's print
Mouse enter and see what we have on my
Center demand Center okay let's see what
we get
oh yeah here we go math because has item
is never true so let's actually let's
make this true no matter what let's
delete that okay
let's play
and now it should only print
there we go so now we print the one that
we actually printed so let's uh change
everything back if that should be let's
remove this so as you can see what what
my little body happened is on Mouse
entered it didn't trigger because we're
also checking for if has item which is
actually good that means it won't we
won't be able to do anything in our
inventory if I I don't even have an item
so it's not even registering that my
mouse has entered because there's no
well it did register but there's no item
in here to have so there's nothing there
to do I can't click anything so that's
good so um that's it let me in the next
part we are going to actually fill our
slots full of information so all right
so I continuing on from our fail slot
inventory all right fail inventory slots
now we're going to actually fill
everything with information okay so we
have to think about this in two parts so
there's two things we have to do the
first is we actually have to clear
everything now why are we doing this why
are we clearing what even is clearing so
clearing is we're going to set all the
information like this we have to take
all the information in each slot and
reset it to zero essentially now why are
we doing this well because
if I only filled all the informations
with slots or all these slots with
information
I wouldn't be able to distinguish or be
able to separate which ones have
information which ones don't now the
best way to do this is just to clear
everything right it's the easiest way
it's not the best way but it's the
easiest so what we'll do here is we'll
clear all Slots of all information we'll
reset everything and the nice part about
this is that now we can
fill all these slots with
inventory info
now here we're actually going to
for Loop i n not inventory size but in
in Dot
inventory
okay because we only need to fill the
slots with the information of how many
items we have from our inventory so here
we'll just pass for now so we don't get
an uh error and in here now what we can
do is we can say
get child dot i
is equal to nothing dot item name so we
can do this for each uh information
things we have so let's copy all these
actually
and what we'll do is we'll go back to
our I'll just say in our slot and then
in our inventory container we can
actually copy paste this
let's do that and what we can do is we
can say get child.i and copy it into
each variable
here like this
and now we've reset every single thing
that we need okay
um let me just double check some things
we also need to say has item is false so
we're going to also say has item is
false for each of these and that's it
now uh let's delete that and now we
actually fill it so here we've reset
every slot to have no information in
them now here we want to actually fill
each slot with the information from our
inventory okay so the way we can do that
is very similarly we'll we'll just take
all these and copy paste it and we'll
say has get child.i or get child I dot
get item name
is equal to not nothing but in fact we
actually want to get our inventory
I dot name so we want to get the name of
our I right so this refers to the like
let's say zero let's say I have uh in
our inventory here it is if I have an
item here let's actually do that let's
add in an item
manually so we'll say zero and then
preload icon and then here we'll say
count
is one let's say two actually and then
I'm going to get an error here because I
didn't add a comma okay so now I have an
item
now in our inventory container we're
going to get access to it by saying
because I starts at zero so it'll get
child zero I set the item name to
inventory 0 at name so it'll go
inventory 0 which is right here and then
we'll we'll go here and get the name
which is Green Arrow okay now we want to
do this for everything so we'll actually
just copy paste this
and
I want you to refill everything okay
now fill everything that you think is
proper here right so hopefully you've
paused and unpaused now all we have to
do is just copy these from description
you have to get the cost
right here good luckily it's all in
order except for the type I think let's
go type uh type is over here and this is
count
and that is it so we also have icon but
we'll do something different for that
okay now we also have to say has item is
row
okay and lastly we have to now load the
icon so let's say get child I dot icon
no we're going to say get node
icon okay and then we're going to say
dot texture
is equal to whatever we want now the
texture is actually going to be
the icon texture so we can say
we can say it like this the inventory
dot I uh inventory icon so here what
we're doing is we're essentially from
our UI from our inventory container if
we have some slots in there we're going
to go into our first child let's say our
first slot and we're going to go into
that slot right so here we're going to
get the icon and we're going to fill the
texture so here's our texture let's say
let's actually put a default texture for
now
okay that'll be our texture let's make
it a little smaller we're gonna have to
resize it once we get proper items in
but this will be our thing so let's hide
that
and let's actually reset this so I know
it works
okay let's play and see what we get so
um let's actually make sure we've called
this
okay so here we have it in the ready
function another place I actually call
this
isn't just the ready because the ready
function calls this once in an entire
game right or every time the scene is
loaded now I don't want that I want it
to actually also be called if I ever
click inventory if I ever open my
inventory I should also
update my inventory so let's actually do
this and say we'll get the node and fill
the inventory
okay so let's play and let's press e
and there we go there's our there's our
slot item and now I can click it and
it'll print Green Arrow awesome we now
have access to our slot and we can
interact with it using input okay
let's
edit a few things in our inventory input
here because
there's a few problems when I'm in my
game if I click e twice it just keeps
putting it back in now I want it to if
it's here I want to be able to press e
and have it leave our screen okay so
what we can do is
here what we'll say the way I do there's
a lot of ways to do this really you can
check for pause tree you can do whatever
the way I do this it's really simple I
just check for the offset so I'm going
to say if the offset of
I'm not going to say self here I'm going
to say the inventory
if the inventory dot is it offset though
for this let's check let's go to layout
and no it is not offsite its position
okay so we're going to check for the
position.y now if the position dot Y is
equal to negative 5 650 that means it's
outside of our screen and it's above us
okay now if it's
zero like that that means we want to get
it off our screen so we can also check
for it we can say LF
we'll say let's actually just do this
and we'll copy this and go here L and
copy now if the inventory position is
zero what we'll do is we'll say Okay
paused is equal to false and then here
also transition out and then Mouse mode
will be
captured okay there's one more thing we
have to check for I think let me just
double check
um here
yeah so when we transition out remember
that we leave it at
650. so here what we can say is let's
actually put this in Brackets
and then we can also add or
let's copy this hopefully this will work
and I don't have to add an alif in my
reference I add an alif so I don't but I
don't think I have to I think I can just
do this
okay so let's play and try it so let's
press e there we go and when I press e
again it disappears and if I press e
now the beauty of this the reason why
this is actually really cool and the
reason why I check for this is because
if you were to check for something else
and you press E I want you to test this
I want you to press e and start spamming
e you can't hear me but I'm spamming e
now the beauty of this is that it
doesn't cut the screen it doesn't cut
the inventory halfway through if the
inventory is going down and you press
again it doesn't reset the animation
usually when you play an animation you
can interrupt that animation by playing
it again now we don't want that to
happen but that won't happen because
here we're setting for we're checking
for the exact position right so here
what's happening is if I press e it
won't play the next animation until I
get to position zero or position any of
these checks that I'm I'm checking for
right so it won't do that it simply
won't so that's the beauty of this code
okay
I think that is it for this part I think
we have everything working
let me just we'll check okay
everything's working so let's continue
on our slot I want to actually be able
to interact with our slot and do things
with it so
the first thing we have to do is
we have to create a
a UI that I can interact with the
information or the actual item now we
have this slot we have the interaction
with the slots now we don't have
anything to interact with the slot
information so let's make that
so let's create a new node let's
actually go to the skeleton and close
that and the player we don't need those
open right now let's create a canvas
layer
it's a canvas layer we'll rename this to
item info
let me just double check that's what I
called it yeah item info and then enter
item info we're going to have a bunch of
things so what are those things well
first of all let's go to 3D scene
because that's what we need let's save
this as item info let's put it here
and let's add our panel I'm going to
have a background for a panel
and we're going to basically have this
as our
reference of item so we're going to put
all the information item name icon all
those things okay so in our this will
rename this to background
let's also add an animation player
and we'll rename this to anim
we'll also add a label
we'll duplicate it because we're going
to have one label for the title and then
one label for the uh
oops ignore that Amazon order
yeah so for the label this will be our
description
and this will be our
um title yeah that's what I call it so
let's actually put this on the top
and let's put a default thing so let's
say item name
and let's resize everything to how we
want it so let's go to the description
and say this
this is a uh
description
[Music]
of our item
now we have to Let's yeah let's change
everything so let's Center everything
and then let's also put auto wrap on
Word Smart now let's resize this and put
it we'll put it right here why because
we're actually also going to have an
icon we'll put that right here
and let's resize it to be proper so
let's actually go to the transform
uh transform here we go and we'll set it
to 0.6 for both of them
or not hit points six yeah there we go
and we'll Center that hopefully
somewhere and we'll drag this down let's
actually drag everything down a little
bit let's take our item name and drag
this here
we'll Center everything
put everything on word smart and then
we'll also go to theme override font
nope font size and then I'll increase it
a little bit
okay and you can kind of mess around
with this you can even add your own
theme I would definitely recommend that
especially if you're making your own
game the default Godot theme is not the
best it's pretty they actually improved
it in good 04 but uh it's just a default
font right so I would suggest going
online and looking for a better font
that you like and that matches your game
okay
the description
um let's resize that like this looks
fine and
we are going to have a few items or
buttons to actually interact with this
so let's add a few buttons so let's add
a button let's add two buttons
it's actually uh leave one
we'll take one for now and then just
duplicate it here so it's easier to drag
actually Let's Not Duplicate it yet what
I'll do is I'll resize it
I'll say close
and then let's resize it to how we want
let's put it like that and then I'll
duplicate it so that way they both have
the same size okay we'll say this is use
so let's rename them as well so this is
use and this is close
and I think that is it for now that is
it awesome so now let's also make the
animation player work so in our
animation We'll add a few things so
we'll go here and we'll say Trans in
Trad es out we'll transition in and
transition out so from transition out
it's actually really easy we have here
so we can go to transform we'll say the
offset is here
and then off we want to say the Y is 650
I guess
yeah that looks nice okay let's key that
and so now we have transition out and
then again transition in
um actually what I do
I don't do this actually we'll do what I
do so let's actually reset this to 0.1
and what I do is I just set the position
right away I don't and I don't animate
this usually because the transition in
and out of the item name I want it to be
instant I don't want it to smooth in and
out because it's not something that
needs animation when I click an item I
want to be able to navigate quickly
right
so in our transition n will actually
reset this to zero
and key that
keep these there we go
we'll go to our reset and our default
will be 650.
so our reset will be this and I'll key
this so this will be our default and
then if I transition in it should pop in
like this the time of the animation
doesn't really matter but yeah I'll just
set it to 0.1 and then transition out
it'll put it outside the screen okay so
back to our slot here now what we can do
is or should do is get access to the
item info so let's decide where to put
this let's put this inside of our
inventory so let's go here
and item info so we'll drag this in to
our Here and Now from our slot we need
to be able to get access to this so
where is our slot well first of all we
don't even have a slot so it's actually
added and it'll make it a little easier
to get access to it so for much slot
script we can actually just do this item
info
now let's actually just load uh
should I I don't know if it'll error
let's try it let's try seeing if we can
load it
let's go to the top
say on ready there
item
info
is equal to this and let's pass and
let's play and let's see what we get
okay I don't think it aired so let's
actually try to actually animate it now
if I click so let's say item info Dot
uh
get node
NM dot play
Trans in okay so let's try that and see
what happens so now when I click on
these slot it should transition in and I
spelled it wrong so let's make sure I
don't capitalize that let's try again
and there we go there's our our slot so
the first thing we have to do I realize
is that the layer is on the same layer
so let's actually make it in the front
and now we have our layer in the front
so now we have our item info here okay
um
yeah that's it so we now have access to
our item info and next part in the next
part will actually fill in the item info
with our information from the slot as
well so
for now uh I want you to just adjust
everything how you'd like it add
backgrounds change the backgrounds all
that stuff so yeah okay welcome back so
let's get right into the filling our
slot information from our slot so as you
remember we check for the left click we
check if our Mouse is in that slot and
we can now play transition in now I want
to actually feel the information with
all the information that we need so
from our slot
all we need to do it's very similar to
feeling from our inventory where is it
from
okay first of all let's delete this slot
from here it's very similar to this
filling into our actual item info so
from our slot we want to get our item
info
dot item name and just fill in item nine
now this is going to be a bit confusing
because it has the same name but this
item name will be from here and we're
going to get the item info name of here
of the item info if that hopefully that
makes sense because if it doesn't um
it's going to get a bit confusing you
should I should have probably named it
something else but
um it's okay I think it's fine so let's
duplicate this a few times
and what we'll do is we'll just copy
paste this for everything
we'll go item cost
item cost item count
item count and we also have
item type
it's copy paste that one more time
we have item type awesome and lastly we
also we
will want to
oh yeah we also want to set the texture
so we say item dot info dot get node
uh let's say icon and then we have to
actually make sure that we go into our
item info oh it's already named icon I
forgot I did that nah I'm so smart we
say item info dot get icon and we'll
fill it in with what we currently have
for this icon so we'll say item icon dot
texture
hopefully I think that yeah that's what
I have and why is it doing this oh
yeah we don't want to say texture
and there we go okay now what we want to
do
what I want to do is
I want to make the process of the
inventory
false so here we're going to get the no
we're going to get parent from our uh
slot we're gonna get parent
to
from here to here to here so we're going
to go here and we're going to disable
the
inventory so we're going to disable the
process of the actual inventory now the
reason we're doing this is because
actually let's
yeah we're gonna disable the inventory
here because what's happening is if I go
here let's actually disable it manually
and see what happens
so if I press e it'll pop up but if I
press anything nothing's happening so
because and it was kind of buggy and the
reason that happens is because we've
disabled it manually so here you can see
that we can't even interact with any of
them so let's actually reset this now
the reason I want to do this is because
okay let's play and
here we go here's our item info and we
already got bugs very cool invalid set
index
item name let's go here
item name
why is that happening item info dot item
name invalid set interacts with value
type strength so
on base canvas item IC okay so we might
have to get the node itself so item info
here oh we didn't even add a script
that's probably why
okay so enter item info we're going to
want to add a script to that
and we're gonna just copy paste this
sorry about that we have item type we
have a bunch of stuff very cool
okay so you can just copy paste this
part right here should be the exact same
okay now let's play again and try that
hopefully we don't get an error okay so
if I click this
nothing's going to happen so let's find
out why all right we're going to have to
debug a few things already
okay
let's take all this out and see what
happens
oh no I remember why okay so let's reset
that
okay so what happened is I actually this
actually did work but it disabled it
right away so the reason why that
happened is because now in here we have
to actually make this process always so
let's okay again let's go again let's
click it in
slot and this pops up now the reason I
disable this is because if I have other
item slots here I can click them and
this will pop up and remove it and the
problem with that is that if my mouse is
over here or actually let's say right
here you can see my mouse
and if I click or even if my close
button was over here and I click on top
of it and the slot is behind my mouse
it'll click both of them and it it won't
be able to distinguish which one I'm
clicking on so as a solution I just
disable the actual inventory see here I
can't even click the button I can hover
it but I can't click it it doesn't do
anything well obviously there's no way
to get back so let's actually just close
the game and keep going so
from our slots
we now have filled the item info with
everything we need that's actually I
didn't even look let's check that to see
if it actually works so here we should
have item name
um
it's weird actually it should be green
arrow should it not let's um
print the item name see what we get
I believe it should be green arrow so I
don't know why it's not working oh no I
know why it's not working because we're
not doing anything with that information
aha
okay
we're going to want to update the
information so um
just one second
okay
um what we want to do here
is
we want to create a function where we
update the information so we can say
update
info
and we'll just add get node title dot
text is equal to item name and then
we'll say the description is going to be
equal to the item description plus the
cost now this is new line so we'll just
go to the next line and then add the
cost that's how I usually add it and
here now what we can do
is we can actually call this every time
I click on a slot so like all I have to
do is say
item info dot uh update info let me just
double check that's how I do it in my
yeah that's how I do in my reference
okay awesome now when I play and I click
the slot item it should pop up with the
information unless I get a
cool error okay what's the error invalid
okay you know what let's just convert
everything to a string so I don't get
any errors
okay invalid set with base
oh that's why I spelled this wrong
that's not why okay so in our item info
here we have description like this and I
didn't get the node properly okay
okay let's try one more time there we go
now we have green arrow this is a green
arrow with cost 10 and this is the icon
that we use for that green arrow so
let's close this and let's add in a
signal for the close so let's actually
go to our closed and press and let's
also add a signal from our use
and that's it so let's add these two now
yeah that's it for now so let's
also add
something that will actually have used
for later so we're going to check for
the item type if the item type is equal
to a misc we're actually going to take
the use and update it to use now if I
have something else that I want to equip
I'm actually going to say else I could
you could do L if but I'm just going to
do else because I only have two types in
my game
so I'm going to say get item uh get node
use
and say dot text is equal to
equip okay
and now I can have in my inventory if
this is a misc it'll say use now if it's
something else I'll just say right hand
I'll play the game
and pop this up now it'll say equip
instead okay so now we can change the
text depending on what type it is so
I'll change this back to a misc or
whatever you want maybe it's a back item
or whatever okay so it's really up to
you and now let's go back to our item
info and we're going to do this next
okay all right welcome back
so
the next thing we're going to do is
realize that I cheated a little bit and
I I actually have a pack from the same
artist with um different
items but um I think
I think they have it yeah so I have more
but you should be able to get these same
items here and now I'm going to actually
adjust everything to fit these icons so
for the item info I'm just going to put
on a random one
and I'm going to adjust it properly so
that it actually has the proper scale so
I want it to be that big
okay and now for the slot I'm also going
to do that for here so I'm going to add
in a slot item and I'm going to adjust
it so that it fits the actual slot
and then let's also adjust the count and
move that up here
let's actually move it right there
and what we'll do is I'll actually we'll
make the font a little smaller so we'll
say
maybe 15 actually maybe 16. no that's
the same size let's do 10.
nope
12. let's do 12. and then I'll adjust it
right there and I wanted to start
reading from the right so let's actually
adjust the vertical to the
uh yeah let's do Center and right so
that way it'll start reading from the
right to left okay now I can adjust it
here and the more numbers I have it'll
read to the left and then auto wrap will
put on smart
and that's it for these count so now the
count will look a lot better so let's
say let's just put it at like 100
um usually most games will cap their
account at 100 so that's good and now
lastly let's go to our script go to our
inventory and
or this let's add a staff so let's go
here and look for a staff
uh it's hard to see but I think let's
like drag it out
that one is not really a staff
I don't know if there is a staff well
that one looks like a staff okay we'll
use that one leaves item iron weapon 28
and then for the Green Arrow I don't
think there are green arrows
obviously so we'll use
what is this that looks like an arrow
kind of not really
yeah
you'll probably want to add your own
proper icons but for a placeholder just
so you can understand the
difference in the game we'll just put
this for now so we have 27 28 so we have
two different icons now um they actually
look proper and let's actually delete
this
because that item doesn't technically
exist anymore and and
let's now go into our UI
item information and let's actually make
this stuff work okay so the first thing
we want to do
is let's let's load our animation so
let's say unready and M
I will say anim dot equals get node
NM and now what I can do is on close I
can just say anim dot play
trans out
and then what I can also not can I
should do uh I'm gonna have to say
variable annum I should do is I have to
set the
process function of our get parent to
true so the get parent is going to be
this guy the inventory which I set to
false when I click the slot if you
remember so now the close should work so
now when I open an item I'm going to
have nothing because I didn't add
anything so in our inventory let's
actually add a function ready
no let's actually test this somewhere
else so let's copy our add item
and what I'll do is I'll add a staff
so I'll say add item
staff
and let's copy that take that and what
we'll do is let's put it
in
here for now so we'll say in and so all
we have to do to add an item from
anywhere in the game is this if dot add
item staff and call its item name okay
so now what we can do is play and now I
should have a staff in my inventory cool
and now I should be able to close and
interact with this I equip doesn't do
anything however you see here we can we
can't click the close button so here if
I close I can now close the inventory
cool and now we have a pretty functional
inventory system
okay so let's close this
and now let's go back to our item info
and we want to make the use work now how
do we do this so I want you to think
about this yourself and
I'll give you a hint there's two cases
where
there's two cases that
affect our use button so there's two
things that we need to do or check for
I'll say that check for so I want you to
think about it and on pause the video
and on think or on pause okay so
hopefully you've thought about it now
these two things that we have to check
for is we've actually done this before
is one if we have the item already and
two if we don't have or if we don't
if the item count is is one if the item
count is one
then we want to get rid of the item
completely from our inventory right
because we're going to use our item
let's say we're drinking a potion oh
and we have 10 potions and I want to
drink one potion all I have to do is say
count minus equal one right that's easy
I just subtract from the count however
let's say I have one potion left and I
drink that potion I want to remove it
from the inventory I don't want to just
subtract the count I want to remove it
completely now how do we do that well
the first thing we have to do is for
Loop through our inventory so the first
I want to do is for loop I in inventory
and then we're going to check to see if
we can find the item name this is to
check if we have the item at all
that first of all okay first of all this
is to check the if we have the item at
all but we also wouldn't be able to even
press this or press the button if we
didn't have an item so it wouldn't
really matter but this is really just to
find the item so we're gonna basically
for Loops through our inventory and find
the item that we're trying to use so the
item name is up here so we're going to
find the item in our inventory right
this isn't only just to check if we have
it this is to find our actual position
or in our inventory right so let's say
I'm trying to use a potion at the third
slot that means the I will be two
because it starts at zero it goes zero
one two right
so now we have
um we have
what do you call it
um access to our I
our inventory item okay so now what we
want to do is
we want to
let me just double check something
we want to remove from the item so what
we'll do is actually really simple we'll
just say item count minus equal one now
what we can do is we can just check to
see if the item count is zero or if it's
if it's not zero right so what we can
say is if item count is zero then we
have to we want to remove item from the
inventory that's it okay
we'll have an else statement for else
well yeah we'll have an else for
something else later but that's it so if
our item count is zero now we want to
actually remove it from the inventory
well actually We'll add it right now so
we'll say else
um count minus
subtract one count from the inventory
count
lot uh variable
okay and this is actually really easy
let's do this part first because this is
super easy it's one line of code
bam we're done that is it we're gonna
because we have the position of where
our inventory item is we just take the
count and we subtract from one right and
that's it that is literally it's the
easiest thing in the world right
and
yeah and that's it now removing for an
item from the inventory is a little
harder it's actually a lot harder than
you might think so to do this we have to
actually create a temporary dictionary
to hold our inventory okay so what we're
going to do is we're gonna for Loop
through our dictionary again we're gonna
go we're going to have to do X because
we already used I so we're going to say
if for Loop r x in inventory and then
we'll say
if x is greater than I then we'll take
our dictionary
and we're going to basically copy every
so what we're doing is we're going to
look we're going to for Loop through our
item no let me explain this a different
way so if I have five items in my
inventory
I and I'm using the item at position
three so it's somewhere in the middle I
can't just copy I can't tell the the
system okay let's copy everything to the
left and right we have to manually do
this so in order to manually copy
everything we have to first check okay
in our inventory let's check everything
to the left of our
inventory from our item use so let's say
we're using an item at position three
and I I have five items in my inventory
at position three I'm going to go from 0
to 2 and copy everything and put it in
inside of our item or temporary
dictionary okay that's what this line is
right here
okay and then now I want to go to the
right of that item and print and copy
everything to the right of that item so
essentially we're going to be copying
everything in our inventory except for
the one item that we are using right so
now
we have to have an LF function and say
if x is smaller than I then we'll copy
everything to the left I believe this is
the left
okay now we've essentially copied
everything into our temporary dictionary
except for that one item that we are
using now why would we do this well it's
actually really simple now all we have
to do is clear our inventory
this is a function built in gudo it's a
dictionary
thing so now we can all we have to do is
say inventory equals temptic because
we've copied over the temporary
dictionary
into a we've copied in our inventory
into the temporary dictionary without
the item we can now just set it equal to
Temporary dictionary and that is it and
now what we want to do because we've
used up the last item we're actually
just going to close our item info so we
can just call this function up here so
we can say on closed pressed okay now
the last thing we have to do is fill our
inventory slots because now we could do
it here but we could also do it here
just to update so this will allow us to
update our inventory right because the
count won't update automatically we have
to actually do that so we have to from
our inventory item information thing we
go up to inventory and then we're going
to go back down to inventory container
and then we're going to re we're going
to update our inventory so let's try
that let's see what happens so when I
play
I open my inventory here's my thing I
equip or use it and it disappears
because the count was uh one so let's
actually add two items let's add staff
add staff
and let's print it
now when I play if I use this
I gotta update it wait was I not
updating it here
oh I don't think I was okay I think what
I have to do
is we have to
let me just double check my reference on
what I did
nope I think okay so what's happening
what I believe is happening and most
likely is happening is oh I think we
might actually be able to do this in the
slot so what's happening is the process
function is the process is paused on the
UI here so it's not able to update
now
so it's not able to call this function
right actually unless I put it in the
wrong line
let me just double check
nope it should be there
yeah it should be in that line
um
let's
double check I named this right it's
actually just do this
nope it's the right path fill inventory
slots that should be the right function
name okay cool
and
let's go back to our inventory item
let's try one more time and see what we
get
let's go here we'll equip it close and
yeah it only updates when it closed so I
think what we have to do is we'll have
to say
we'll we'll say always and then we'll
pause it again
so we'll say process
raw SAS mode uh disabled there we go and
so let's try that and see if that works
hopefully
nope it doesn't work why is that that's
interesting
um item count
um let's we should actually be able to
do this manually oh no we just have to
update the info
of our slot so
let me actually figure this out and I'll
be right back all right so I figured out
a way I don't know why it's not working
for here but it is working for my
reference
um basically all we will do to allow our
account to update but avoid errors in
clicking our slot is in the process of
our label we'll go to always or mode and
put it to always so now it'll always
update no matter what because the
process is always going to be working so
now if I equip or close it'll work
properly okay so that's that's that
fixed so we still have this there to
avoid any errors in clicking the slot
while our inventory item information is
up
all right so that is everything for the
using the button next up I believe we
are going to create the equipments the
equipment system
okay next up we are going to be doing
our equipment system okay so let's get
that set up first in visuals and then
we'll also do the script so the first
thing the visual will actually be pretty
easy for the equipment we'll actually
have it local so we'll have it as a
node and we'll say equip
and we'll move this
let's move this into the inventory
because it's going to be part of the
inventory and then in here we're
actually just going to let's do this
let's go into our inventory go to slot
we'll drag that in and let's find our
slot but pop that in and we're going to
make it local and then we're going to
delete the count because our equipments
don't have account and then let's go
over here and disconnect
everything
we want to go into our script and we're
going to delete the script we're going
to go to our slot and rename this head
okay so here let's move this up maybe
right there actually I'll move it right
here
um it's hard to see where this is so
let's pop that in there and
let's move this one pixel to the right
whoop it's really hard to move Pixel
Perfect okay and let's duplicate this
um a few times so we have one two three
four five and I think that's good so
let's actually select the move button by
clicking W or selecting it and we'll
just move each one of these a few pixels
down so we'll have the head the chest
the legs this will be the feet put that
down there this will be the left hand
that right there and this will be the
right hand
let's actually move
that
end that a few pixels up
there we go
okay so let's rename everything this is
going to be the chest
we have
legs
this will be
the feet
this will be the
left hand
and this will be the
right hand but I have to rename it right
and
okay so here we now need to create a
script that will work for all of these
so in our inventory let's create a new
folder for this let's say equip
equip
and in this script we are going to
go into here well we have to first
create the scripts let's say script
we'll say equip
uh let's actually rename it to something
uh no actually let's go to equip and
then here all we're going to do is we're
going to have the same variables as our
item slot this is going to be pretty
similar to our item slot in fact
we can actually go into our item slot
and just copy some things over I think
we should actually be able to just copy
all this over go into our well first
okay let's go back to our clip and add
this we don't have a count so we're
actually going to remove that
and then enter here we're actually going
to set the texture in our process so
here we'll say
um at the icon
okay I'll copy it over icon dot texture
is going to be equal to
this is going to err for you but I'm
going to put this for now okay so we're
going to say inventory.equip
at stringself.name at The Icon so let's
actually explore what this means and
we'll actually create it in the script
so let's actually go to our equip and
close all other tabs let's open our
Global inventory and in our inventory
we're going to add a new dictionary in
this dictionary we're going to have it
called be called equip so I'm actually
going to copy
let me copy it over the first one and
then I'll copy the rest over and just
explain what it all does so the first
thing we're going to have is a variable
dictionary called equip and in this
equip like dictionary we're going to
have
six seven seven keys each one is going
to be its own head chest legs feet left
hand and right hand each one is going to
be unique so we're going to have head et
cetera et cetera okay and each one of
those is going to have an item inside of
it that item is literally from our
inventory right so it has the exact same
things has a count um the count won't
really matter because we're not going to
be using it but we're just going to pass
it over anyways so from our icon
well actually why don't we load
something proper so we can load
uh let's load the weapon
no actually let's load something else so
that way we see if it changes
okay so from here we now have head and
all that stuff so we want you want to
make you're going to want to make one
for each
um
thing so I'm gonna just copy this over
for my reference and I'll quickly just
scroll through it a little bit so here
we have head chest legs
feet right hand and left hand if you
want more things you can do that really
easily okay I'll be showing you how to
implement all of these pretty easily so
um here for these
um
image we're probably going to want to
actually load something proper again for
all of them so let me just do that real
quick and there's a fast way to do this
for me so if we just select this and say
Ctrl R and replace all it'll replace all
of them to the iron shield and no more
errors cool so it doesn't really matter
what we preload but as long as we reload
something so that way we can load
something in later
okay so all of these are default so it
doesn't matter what it is because we're
going to actually load it and change it
later anyways so now what we want to do
is
in our texture we are now equipping it
with the we're setting the texture to
the equip.string self name so if we have
a name called
um let's say green arrow we're going to
find the Green Arrow and put that in the
texture of that green arrow right so
we'll load the icon here as well so if
we had green arrow it'll load that icon
as well okay and next up
we have Mouse entered in Mouse exited so
we're going to actually want to First
we're going to want to
let's see if this actually works I've
never tried this
oh it does okay okay this is a cool
trick so if we select the legs and hit
control and select the feet left hand
right hand and we actually drag the
equip we can just select all of them and
add the script to all of them at once
now let's see if this no it won't work
okay so we're gonna have to manually add
the mouse entered and mouse exited to
each one manually so
let's do that right now so let's just
add all these
Mouse entered
[Music]
oops
um
all right so now each one has its own
connection
and now what we can do is
we will want to actually have
so originally
the you could do you have two options
really you can either create another
item info for the equipment or what
we're going to do is we're going to just
use the item info for our equipment so
we're going to use this to have our item
information on our equipment here so the
first thing we'll want to do is actually
go from inventory to having it equipped
so in our item information we're going
to go into our script
and now that we have the equipment thing
this is just text so there's a lot of
different ways to do this really is
either we we create another button
that's equipped or we just check for
equipment or there's so many different
things we can do but
I'll show both so the first thing we're
going to do is we're going to use we're
going to take the use button and have it
as a from the inventory to whatever so
we have few options either it's in our
inventory and it's a misc item and if it
is a mask item we'll drink a potion
whatever we'll use the effect of that
item if it's a equipment right if the
type is equipment or um if the type is a
right hand we'll do something with it so
on our use press button
let me just go to my reference
in here what we'll do is we're going to
first
check for the path so the first thing we
want to do okay let me see if I can
pull up my reference so this is going to
take you a while
to type out so I'm going to just copy it
so the first thing you might think of
doing is okay well if we want to get the
type of the equipment what we can do is
we can use mash so match is a really
good thing to learn but in this case so
what we would be doing
as we would be saying okay we're going
to take the inventory I type and we're
going to match it with all of these
right so the reason why we're doing this
is because we want to see what the type
is if the type of the
inventory that we're using is ahead then
we can equip it right if it's uh legs
then we'll equip it in the legs section
right so here we we get the path
manually of each thing so if it's leg oh
I'm sorry legs twice uh say feet
now that this works but it's kind of
inefficient it's really long and it'll
take a while right so I don't want you
to do this but this is a good idea of
what how we can one option of what we
could do now instead what we'll do
we're going to get access to the path of
the type and this this is really
important you have to make sure that the
equipment and the type here on the left
are spelled the same otherwise you'll
get an error so the path is going to be
equal to equip so get parent equipped
right here
slash string we're going to add the type
of their inventory so if our type is
head it's going to get the path to head
does that make sense so if we in our
inventory if we have type head the path
will be equal to get parent equip slash
head which is right here so we will now
have access to our head depending on
what sort of type we're equipping right
so here we have type uh head and chess
well these are in our equipment but if
we had something here so we have weapon
we don't want weapon we want right hand
okay so this is very important that we
make sure that it's right hand or left
hand or whatever else here okay so in
our item info now what we can do is
check to see if the path exists we can
say has
node path if it does
what we can do
is we'll say Okay first we'll see if
that if that thing has an item if it
does or doesn't then we'll make item has
true
and then we'll just load in the item
that we have okay now if it's not no I'm
not going to do this but if it if it
doesn't exist I want you to tell me what
does that mean if the path that we're
trying to access of the equipment that
we just made doesn't exist what does
that mean
okay so if if it doesn't exist that
means that this is a missed item so
we're just going to print that this is a
missed item now if you want to create
some sort of effect where you add Health
to the player you can do that here you
can We'll add a comment here
um use misc item effect
example
healing
Buffs
Etc
okay so if you have any sort of buff
healing thing whatever this is where you
would do it if we're equipping this is
where we do it let's actually add a
comment here equip
the item in use in question
no I will say in use I think that makes
a bit more sense okay
now I think that is done so I think we
actually might be able to test it
um I think we have a staff in our
inventory so let's just play and see
what we get so here we go we have no
slots I'm not sure why
um if we use it
nothing pops up why is that I know why
because this is a node and it stayed up
there okay we might have to change this
let's
um
change
where's change type there it is change
type to node 2D
and we'll actually try one more time oh
where our head our inventory went over
there okay let's
let's just bring this down
all the way here
actually no I'll uh we'll do this we'll
take all these and then we'll drag it
down there we go we'll put it right
there hopefully it's not on top of the
inventory it is so let's move it a bit
more to the left
okay there we go okay let's play one
more time this should work
okay here's our inventory now I equip
and there it is there's our item so if I
equip one more time it'll disappear so
we'll we'll fix that later but for now
we have now equipped something so now I
want to be able to click this the item
and unequip it so let's actually move
this a bit more to the left because I
noticed it was still
yeah let's put it right there I think
that's good okay so now from our slot I
want to be able to print or do something
so here what we can do actually is we
can go into our slot and use that as a
reference okay so here remember we have
all this so we'll actually just copy
this and go to our equip and copy that
and then we can say print
item name so why don't we do that
um let's
yeah let's play
here we have nothing equipped so let's
equip something we close it and here's
our item and if I click this nothing
happens why is that
oh I might not have
done this properly let's go to UI let's
go to our head
um right hand let's go to our right hand
and see if that worked
let's see if this actually worked so
let's print something
there's a chance it might not have
worked
oh okay so it did work but it just
didn't print the the name so the name
was not filled in that's good okay
so we just haven't filled anything in so
it is printing but it just hasn't
printed anything proper okay
let me just double check and the other
ones are printing Okay cool so let's
actually take this out
so here we can see that if I click this
it's printing nothing which is the item
name but if I'm clicking on the other
ones nothing is printing because there
is no item in those so let's close this
and in the next part we'll actually work
on filling up the inventory
or the equipment properly
okay one thing I realized is for the
information in that is stored inside of
our equipment
slot we don't actually need these the
reason being because our equipment is
stored inside of our equipment it's
going to be stored inside of our script
so yeah here we're not going to print
the name we're going to uh let's pass
for now let's delete that
and and so we have
the thing equipped inside of our equip
equipped inventory okay so once we've
we've worked on equipping an item now we
have it equipped inside of our Global
script now this is actually really nice
because now if we click on it what we
can do is we'll set the information from
here so in fact we can actually go into
our slot and let's Auto load the same
thing so we'll say
um
from here let's put this slot right here
and so let's go to our equip we'll Auto
load the item information
I will put it right there and let's
actually double check that it's correct
so let's go to our UI let's go to one of
these scripts and let's drag this in
and it is the same path perfect okay
so we've now Auto loaded this let's go
to our slot once more and now we can do
this we'll go to our equip and just copy
this
there we go and so the animation
transition in is good however the rest
of it is not good because we there is no
item name there is no type there is no
none of this right however it is stored
somewhere okay so I want you to think
where is this stored this information
like item name where is it right we have
it somewhere right otherwise we wouldn't
be able to use it here
okay hopefully you figured it out it is
the same thing here right it's the same
idea so in fact
we should just be able to do this
um let me double check if that's what I
actually do I don't think it is
no it isn't but um what I do okay so
for the name we'll do this so item
equip.self name so it's the same thing
right so we're going to take the name of
our head so for example if we're right
hand we're going to look for the right
hand inside of our inventory I'm going
to go inside our inventory inside of our
clip we're going to go to right hand
okay here it is here's our what's in our
right hand and we're going to load it
into the information so into the this
thing I'm going to take the name right
so let's actually copy this all over and
now we can rename this to what it is so
this is type this is count
this is cost and this is description
and now
hopefully no errors okay cool let's play
and we should
be able to equip close this let's open
this and now we have this we have the
staff right now this won't do anything
but it will do something because when we
equipped this is the wrong button but if
we close it that's kind of what we
wanted Okay so
we have the item information with our
from our Equip to the item info now
there's a few things we have to change
or
kind of understand so the first thing we
need to do is understand that the item
info should have two things it should
have a use button an equip button so use
slash equip and now what we're going to
do is we're going to duplicate this and
we're going to say unequip on the equip
now we could rename it as well like here
in our thing but that's gonna
it's gonna require a few other things so
here we'll just say unequip
and now what we can do is we'll make
this hidden and so in our UI from our
slot what we can add is say
no pass on it
we will say
get node
um dot we can actually say like this
actually I'll do it like this
whoops
okay
so we'll say item info dot get node use
and hide and then we'll say we'll get
the unequip
node and show that instead the the
button right so enter item info sorry
let me close the torch and all that I
was playing around with that we're going
to go into our nodes here we're going to
show the use if it's not or we're going
to show the on equip and hide the use If
It Isn't So here let's play
let's go to our system here let's equip
this close this go here and unequip this
and obviously nothing happens and
but that yeah that's it it showed our
unequipped so yeah that's it it works
um now we have to actually uh we have to
disconnect the node because what
happened is it used it and it just
equipped it essentially and now what we
can do is connect this into our node and
do something when we unequip now we're
going to actually unequip it
yeah okay
um we have to
double check that everything is proper
so from our UI things are getting a bit
messy sorry so things are getting a
little complicated but we'll try to keep
track of everything okay so in our slot
from our equip here we can hide and show
everything right
now I believe let me double check that
if we do this
and close okay so here we see that both
are are not hidden so we actually need
to do the same thing if we hit the slot
so in our slot we have to make sure that
we hide and show the proper ones so yeah
let's just do this so here we'll show
the use
and hide the
unequip
on
equip so if we're clicking from our slot
from our inventory we're going to hide
the unequip and show the use right so
it's going to be the opposite
okay things are getting a bit complex
but we're almost done so let's close
that let's go to our Scripts
in our item info we're now going to work
on unequipping so in unequipping
this is very similar
so let's go to my let me let me pull up
my reference real quick
okay so unequipping something is
actually somewhat easier but it's still
somewhat complex so the first thing
we're going to do is we have to check if
we have an item in our inventory already
so the first thing we'll do is we'll
create a local variable inside of our
function called has item this will allow
us to check if we have the item or not
so now what we'll do is we'll for Loop
through the inventory
and now we actually check to see if we
have that item so we can do that by
saying if in in dot inventory at the eye
of our name so if our inventory we're
going to for Loop through it look at
each name and we're going to check to
see if the item type name is the same so
if what we have equipped is the same of
something in our inventory then all we
can do or all we have to do is say item
count is item count plus one and say has
item is uh true and that's it so well no
that's not it but now what we can do is
say
if has item after is false then what
we'll do is we'll say okay well we need
to add it to our inventory so
what we should be able to do
yeah so now what we can do is just say
copy it over to a temporary dictionary
so we're going to copy over our item
from our equipment we're going to add
the count to our equipment and then
we're going to
add it in and that's it I think we
actually might also just be able to
say add item I think we are I think we
might just be able to say add item so
let me let's do that let's uh let's try
this
this is what I have in my
reference but I want to try this
so we can comment that out by adding
three of these and let's say add item
and we'll add
the item this one
I think that should work nope we got to
get the name of it name
okay hopefully uh we have we gotta
reference the global inventory so
inventory dot add item
so if has item is false we'll add it
we'll add the item we'll try that for
now if that doesn't work we'll end up
doing what I did
okay
and then what we'll do is we'll close
the
the item info I also actually want to
close on
equipping where is that equip
what we'll do actually is we'll just
close it regardless
actually
yeah no we'll close it here so we'll say
if uh if it is an equipment then we'll
close it
okay and here we're going to close the
item info but there's still some things
we want to do and
that is we have to remove the item from
our equipment so we should actually be
able to test this see if the ad item
works so let's equip something
and then let's unequip and it should
kind of work well first of all the count
didn't work so that's interesting
Let's uh equip this unequip and
nothing's working okay let's comment
this out and see if this will allow it
to work
okay let's use or equip these twice so
we get rid of it
and unequip and interesting it's still
not working
okay let's see
let's see what's going on
ah right we have to update our inventory
I knew I was swinging something we'll do
that right after so here we'll say get
node inventory container and fill these
slots so let's actually call that
function so we'll fill the inventory
slot and yeah we'll use my method for
now and now what we should do is if I
unequip it yeah it goes count one let's
equip both times and then unequip and it
should unequip it technically there we
go so it does kind of work the only
issue now is we got to remove the item
from our equipment so let's add a
comment say remove item from equip
however
um let's actually sorry I want to test
this part and see if this works we'll
add item
let's try that
we'll equip equip unequip okay it does
work okay so you can do either or so you
can either do this or you can just do
this I think either or would work
actually perfectly because in our ad
item we do the same thing we add count
we check for if it already exists and
then we also add
um so here we can just add item
okay
next up in fact you might actually just
be able to remove all this but I'm going
to test that later and I'll let you know
but the next thing we have to do is
remove it from our equipment and so the
way we do that
is we first get our path to what we have
so we have to access the path of what we
have equipped and the way we do that is
by we have the item type so we're just
going to say path is equal to string
plus item type so we're gonna let's say
right hand we're gonna get the path to
our right hand and then we're going to
get the node of that path and say has
item is false and then we're also that's
pretty much all we have to do we don't
have to reset the information inside of
it well firstly because we don't store
any of the information inside of it and
second because now we'll just set the
information to uh deep Nothing by doing
this so let's uh change that to
something I actually have
iron shield
okay and now
we've essentially reset everything so we
go into our equipment item type right
hand for in this case and say okay we're
now going to set everything to default
okay so now when I play and I equip
something
and I unequip it it goes back in and it
removes it from the slot it's no longer
in our equipment right in fact uh you
could print the equipment and test it
for yourself but I'll let you do that
testing to yourself okay one last thing
I'm going to do is I'm going to actually
test to see if this works so let's
actually just play
and equip unequip okay it does I don't
know why I was doing that then
okay and now I now I know okay so
um unequipping will just require us to
add inventory because in our inventory
we actually do all that checking in here
so I forgot we actually did that and in
our equip
sorry in our item info for unequip we'll
just close right after we'll fill the
slots and then we'll remove it from the
equipment that's the only thing that we
need to do that we need to add so remove
item from equipment
okay the next thing we're going to do in
the next part is we're going to check to
see if we have something equipped which
is going to be right here okay so stay
tuned and we'll do that in a minute all
right so um there was a little bug uh
where when I use an item so let me just
show you the bug I had so here when I
used this up and I use both the entire
inventory cleared and that's because
here I'm actually clearing it in a for
loop I want to do that outside the for
Loop so make sure that this is outside
the for Loop in case uh that's something
that you did as well so let me just
remove that print I was debugging this
earlier and I was so confused as to why
it wasn't working anyways let's continue
on into the equipment so
when I try to equip something that is
already equipped
it's going to equip anyways so what we
can do is actually reverse this and
check if has item is true if it is what
we can do is we can just say add
inventory add item here let me just
let my reference real quick
what we can do
is we can just say this
inventory add item equip item name type
so we'll take the item that we have
equipped and we'll add it to our
inventory and then we'll just do
everything as normal so we'll say has
item We'll add the item into our
equipment Etc et cetera so now when I
play the game
and I have something equipped so here's
our staff if I take our mace and equip
this it'll unequip what I have so add it
into the inventory and then equip what I
have here so if I try this reverse it
should yeah there we go and so what
there is still one bug so here if I have
a staff and I already have a staff
equipped if I equip it'll still equip it
so what I want to do is we want to check
to see if that thing is equipped already
before now this is a little hard because
what's going to happen now is
essentially we want to check to see if
the item we're trying to use is is
already equipped and the same but we
also want to make it work so that this
work works with miscs as well so what we
can do
is we can say okay here we'll say if the
get node.txt is equal to equip
then we will first we'll first check to
see if the
so here we've already checked we'll do
the same thing so we'll say if the
node.path has item or actually what
we'll do is we'll say
we'll put this here as well
so we'll have to get the path because we
don't have the path and then we will ask
okay is this there right
um well we already have access to the
path okay perfect so here we'll say if
get node.path has item is true there is
something in it so now we have to check
okay if that item so we'll say if we'll
get the node we'll say get node.path and
we'll say if the
node.name is equal to
no sorry we have to check the equip so
we have to say
where is it we can probably use one of
the
yeah okay so we'll say uh whoops where
to go okay so we'll ask
so we check if the use binance dot text
is equal to quip then that means there
is something in there if there is
something in there or if we have our
thing is equipped we're trying to equip
something we're going to check if the
path has an item if it does we want to
check if the name of that item is the
same as what we're trying to equip so
what we should be trying to equip should
be this here we go
this guy so we want to check if it's
equal to this now how do we get the name
of what we have equipped currently well
in our UI
in our
the right hand it's a little hard to
check because we didn't save it in our
local variable so what we can do
we got to think about okay how can we
actually check to see if what we have
equipped is already there well you could
go back and add it or what we can do is
instead of checking for the name we can
actually just check for the icon so
instead of the name we'll say get node
we'll get the icon and then we'll say
dot texture
is equal to instead of the equip
actually in fact instead of the equip
what we can do is check our own Icon by
saying get node
icon dot texture and if it is we're
gonna we'll print something for now
already has equipped
there we go
hopefully that should not error okay uh
if oh I have to add an if statement if
okay cool let's try this and see what
happens
let's equip this equip again and as you
can see it says already has equipped so
now what we can do is if we already have
it equipped
um why don't we
we can either add the item again or we
can yeah let's just do that I think
that's the easiest solution honestly
let's try that
so let's go here let's equip and equip
again and nope that's not going to work
because yeah because we're actually
removing It Anyways okay so here what we
can do is we'll say
if
if it doesn't have it
um
we will
say else
then we can do this
so what we'll do instead sorry about
that I just just figured this out real
quick we'll create a variable called
item equipped is equal to false and then
if all of this is true then we'll say
item equipped is true and then at the
very end all we have to do is say If an
item it was equipped then we'll just add
it back into the inventory so there's
probably a better way to do this but at
this point
um it's very long and
this is one of the ways to do it so if
you can figure out a better way to do
this I would definitely applaud you and
you should definitely try to figure it
out but for now this is a very good fix
so now what we have is when I play
I haven't I equipped my staff I try to
equip it again now it'll add it back in
at the very end now obviously this
changes the format of our inventory but
that's okay so now we have As Nice
system where I can equip things unequip
Etc and that's a bug but I'll figure
that out in a minute
all right last bug I'm not sorry about
this guys last bug that we had was
basically what was happening is because
we were checking for the texture and we
say item is equipped is true here well
adding an item
if the icon is the same so it doesn't
actually matter if it's equipped or not
if the texture is the same we're adding
an item so that was the bug and so to
fix that essentially we have to reset
the icon texture to something that isn't
an item so here we say has item is true
but we also have to reset the icon so
what what I did is I reset it to the
default goodo icon it won't matter what
I set it to As Long As I don't use this
item in the game because or this icon
because this icon won't be shown so it
doesn't even matter so now we have a
good working
equipment system so here I can equip I
can equip it'll set here I can unequip
equip Etc
and there's no bugs so it won't reset or
start infinitely adding things into our
item and here I should be able to equip
this and here's our item Awesome
everything in our inventory system works
our equipment system works next up we'll
be making it so that we can actually
equip things and that our sword changes
so stay tuned and we'll do that in a
minute all right so in our and Slot here
in our player remember we added the
sword hopefully I showed you how to do
that if not it's very simple we just had
to add the mesh into our hand slot and
rotate it so that it matches our hand
and now here let's find a let's find a
maze or some sort of other weapon so
let's go into our
cake it skeletons pack and let's go to
the assets
and we should be able to find a bunch of
things so we have swords helmets hoods
Etc we even have staff uh we have a
spell book we have a sword and we have a
sword half I think this is the half one
yeah so let's have the broken one as
well
so let's pop that in here and what we'll
do is I'll just make this local and I'll
pop this in let's delete that and here I
want to copy over all the same values
for the transform so I'll reset that
this will be 180
okay the scale clearly is wrong
or yeah
I reset the scale ah I set the scale to
the wrong thing so 180 90 there we go
okay and then the position let's reset
that and
the position oh it looks like actually
it's already the right side up let's
just set this to 90. so it goes like
that and then the position I believe is
yeah 0.571
nope or not
we'll just manually set it then to right
there
okay
you can copy over the same
Transformations but this is what I'm
going to use okay so now what we can do
is in our process function which we'll
make right now
we will
match the equipment to the sword so what
we'll do
is we'll say match inventory equipment
right hand to name and now we can check
for a specific name so what I'll do
is we can say
um what do we have we have we have to go
to our equipment
and we'll say
iron mace for example so we'll equip if
we have iron mace equipped
here we go if we have iron mace equipped
what I'll do is I'll get the node
let's actually create a function called
Idol this is a very useful function that
I usually do and basically it'll hide
all our
things so I don't have to do this
manually for each node
I'd
so I'll say
hi at all so let me write this out and
I'll explain it so hide all and then
we'll show the one that we want to show
so let's say this is the maze it's not a
maze obviously but let's say it is
we'll say um
No actually that's not re-name it
because I already did that here
uh
here we go iron maze okay and now what
we'll do is we'll say broken swordbroken
dot show and then
here we can also check for what's the
other one that we have staff I don't
know why we're equipping a staff but
that's okay so here we'll say staff
if it is we'll do the exact same thing
we'll hide all but we'll show this one
instead
now match has a built-in feature where
if I have this this essentially means
else so if there's nothing equipped if
we don't have anything that's matching
these two then we'll just hide off
that's what we'll do
okay so now when I play
hopefully all the errors are gone cool
when I play
I have nothing equipped and now if I
equip our staff and I unequip or I take
out the inventory we see our sword is
equipped now if I equip the mace it'll
change to one of the longer swords
and that's cool so we now have a working
inventory system with our equipment so
we can now equip things now if we want
this to always process what we can do
hopefully this works I actually didn't
test it so we'll test it together so we
can set the process to hand slot always
and now when I equip something it should
automatically switch and you can do this
for all of the bones actually so let's
actually do that let's set all the
process to always and now whenever you
equip anything so this doesn't just work
for sword if you equip anything so let's
say on your body you want to equip
let's go to hide
if you want to equip
a helmet
whoa
we'll put that in here I might do this
on my own time just for fun but I'll
just show you quickly how you can do
that hopefully you've already figured it
out but yeah that's it so we can just
set this and take the rotation and just
put it on top of our character and we
can kind of set it to however it works
and that kind of looks right that looks
like he has equipped and that's it so
you would add all the things or you can
change the mesh there's a lot of
different ways to do this but this is
the way I'm going to teach you so you
can just use a match function but that
allows you to equip and unequip things
so now when I play
[Music]
I have our helmet on which is uh me
hacking technically speaking and then I
can equip items so that's really cool
awesome all right so let's get into our
shop so we're going to create this as a
separate scene so let's go into a new
node we're going to create it as an area
3D that's going to be the base node
inside of here we'll create a collision
shape
here we'll just give it a simple
let's give it a simple sphere
and kind of make it that big and then in
here we're going to call it shop
we'll give it a script in here and why
don't we actually put it inside our
objects
and we can actually make a new folder
for this why not
and here we go so let's put it in here
and save create and then save the shop
scene inside that folder that we just
made
awesome next up we're going to create a
shop interface so the shop itself the UI
this guy is pretty much nothing there's
no not much to it but the UI is where
most the magic is going to happen so
let's create a canvas layer
it's going to be our shop interface
we'll give it shop
I'll name it shop you're going to name
it whatever you'd like but I'm going to
name it shop all right so inside of here
we're going to have a few things or
quite a bit so we're going to add an
animation player
for animating the shop in and out let's
rename it to anim
let's add a control node so that can
contain all our
stuff for our shop let's add a panel for
the background
and for the background or for the panel
let's make it the same size as the UI in
fact actually what we can do is let's
delete that and take our
inventory or UI I suppose yeah here we
go we'll make this local we'll delete
this
and let's pop this out
and delete the UI we don't need that
delete the control
we'll rename this to shop
and in here we can delete the equipment
because we don't need that we don't need
this let's delete that the close we can
keep that but we'll have to disconnect
it for now so let's go down here and
disconnect
some for here we'll go to the title and
rename it to
stop and then we're going to add a few
more things we're going to add some
buttons so let's actually yeah let's
just duplicate this
let's add that here
so the way we're going to do this shop
is once you have a
node here in the middle or Sprite so
let's actually find a random Sprite for
the equipment where did I put the icons
here we go icon all right and we'll put
this guy so here's what we're going to
have we're going to have a big
Sprite or image of what we want to buy
so let's actually look at the transform
let's do seven there we go so let's put
it right there and the close this isn't
actually going to be closed it's going
to be next so we'll go to the right
meaning so if we have a list of things
we'll go to the right and this one we'll
make another one so we'll duplicate it
and this one will go to the left so
we'll just do like that
awesome and then let's have a fourth
button that's going to be purchase so if
we purchase the selected item
okay so let's just try to make this
centered I'm not going to use anything
any containers to make this Center
nicely I'm just going to use
um whatever I like so I'm going to
rename this to next
this to previous
and this to purchase
let's make sure I spell that right and
that is it that's the setup for the node
let's firstly add a script for the shop
let's go over here add a script awesome
and we're going to actually want gold
eventually so let's actually add a label
for that let's take both of these guys
and pop that in there let's take our
label
put it right there and we'll rename this
to gold
let's take that say gold and then in our
label what we'll do we'll do this ours
quickly
um we'll just have a built-in script
here
save this as well let's put it right
let's actually take our oh I can't
really see that as over
uh shop we'll say shop UI
okay let's go to our shop actually I
think I saved these shop scripts
somewhere else yeah there it is so let's
actually move that shop script in here
although that might
not work because yeah so I have to
rename this guy as well so shop UI
and then let's take this guy in here
awesome and for a gold what we'll do is
we'll have a global gold value so in our
game script oh we already do awesome so
enter the script here what we'll say is
text equals
um
gold
plus string game dot gold
and that's it so now it'll print out our
gold right there okay all right so from
here we're going to go into our shop
actually let's animate our shop first so
that way we can actually interact with
it from our game so from here as you
probably know already all we have to do
is do Trans in and Trends out so let's
add those two fans out and from Trans in
we'll go from here so let's uh take our
shop go to layout transform and take our
position key that we'll create a reset
why not we'll go here and we'll reset
that go to zero key that so now we have
this and in Trends out we'll go from 0 0
here
the key that right there and then from
here we'll go to 650.
whoops 650 if I can type there we go
and now we have a transition outwards
okay so in our reset let's
set this as our starting position so in
our shop all we have to do now is well
first of all we have to actually add or
shop UI so let's add this in in our shop
now all we have to do
is firstly we have to connect the body
entered
in here and then in the body entered so
we have to make sure that we check if
the body is the player so we'll say if
layer
in body dot name
then we'll do a bunch of things first we
can pause the tree so we can pause the
game and then we'll get the shop
animation so we'll say get node shop
slash anim play transition in and then
we're also going to make our Mouse shown
so we're going to make our Mouse visible
okay and from here that's it so let's uh
Delete all this we don't need that
and now from here we can actually go
into our shop and start doing some
things one thing I kind of forgot in my
reference at least that we can add it's
up to you I'm going to duplicate the
title and I'm going to drag it down here
I'm going to go to theme override
set this to 16 Maybe
and this is going to be our description
of the item so let's actually move the
purchase button a little lower
go here and say this is uh description
Okay cool so let's actually move it down
a little bit
and you can position it wherever you'd
like but that's where I'm going to put
it for now okay
in our shop let me just pull up my
reference the first thing we need to do
is we actually need to Let's actually
name this description
connect all the buttons so let's go one
by one and connect all the buttons so
we'll go to pressed
add the next
add previous
and purchase okay now that we've
connected all four buttons let's go here
and delete those two functions
in the
so the first thing we need to do is is
explore the concept of how we're going
to do this so first I want to
understand or we want to understand how
we're going to
switch between items okay so essentially
we're going to hold a variable that has
the current item okay
and then we're also going to have a
variable that points to which item we
have selected okay and then from here
we will
yeah okay so
we need an array right so we need an
array to basically point out which ones
we have selected okay so the reason why
we need a pointer or an array to do that
is so we basically have an array of
things and we point towards which one we
want now we actually already have that
now if you want to make your shop
limited I would suggest you remake it
but what I'm going to use is actually
let's close all this so we have a bit
organized
we have this this is the database of all
the items we have in our game so we're
going to use this as our reference or
array or dictionary of items so we have
0 1 2 right so in here
in our shop we're going to
um
create a function first called switch
item so let's say uh function switch
switch item
and we're going to pass through a select
number this is going to be the number
Select okay so from here let's
for Loop through the inventory and what
we're going to do is we're going to find
the item that we have selected and
return it essentially okay so now what
we'll do is we'll say well because now
we're for looping through the inventory
I think we could actually just well I'll
test it later but for now this is what I
have in my reference we'll say if select
is equal to I so meaning we found the
item that we have in our inventory then
what we'll do is we'll say current item
is equal to select so select will Point
towards which item we have selected and
the current item will hold which item we
currently have selected so they're
almost the same thing it's just to kind
of help us switch okay now from here
the first thing we're going to do now
here's where we're actually changing
everything so here we're going to change
for example the texture of the
where is it this guy so let's actually
rename this to item icon
and then what I can do is I can actually
take this get node and just replace it
with this so say add shop item icon dot
texture we'll change it with the icon of
that current item so here in our items
we're going to go to whatever and take
the icon that is already pre-loaded okay
and then we're going to set that as our
texture now we're going to do this let
me just copy this and then
I'll fix the
stuff so here we can now load in
everything we need so we can load in our
title which is the name of the thing
then we can load in the description and
then here this is the description but I
also want to add the cost so what I can
do here is I can say get the description
instead of setting it equal to we'll
just add to it so we'll say plus equals
Cost Plus string of our cost now this is
a new line so it'll always create a new
line for the cost so you'll see what it
looks like in a second okay now for the
next brought in this is actually the
next previous is actually pretty easy
all we have to do is say
switch item dot current plus one
okay now the previous is the same thing
but we're going to do negative one so
we're going to subtract one okay
now purchase will be something else
that's a different story so let's
um look at that in a second
first let's go to our close button
because it's actually pretty easy we'll
say get tree.pause is equal to false and
then we'll also say
get atom get node anim and play
transition out and then lastly we have
to
let's go to our world let's go to our UI
actually in here we say
we're going to copy the captured and
we're going to capture
our Mouse again so once I close it okay
so let's close next and previous okay
and on our ready function what we'll do
is we'll say function ready and switch
to zero okay so now what we can do is
play
and we'll probably want to add the shop
somewhere so let's go to our world let's
go to our objects and let's add our shop
somewhere so okay what's going on here
description uh we have to name it desk
like that okay let's play One More Time
no that's our inventory
whoa something happened there I'll
figure that out in a second but that's
okay
so let's find our UI actually for our
shop
where is it he's like right there
he's kind of in the middle there okay
let's try to see if I can get to it it
should be somewhere around here there we
go okay
nothing's happening so let's find out
why okay so um I'm not sure why but for
some reason the animation in the trends
in and out for the inventory UI just
stopped working and I had to redo it
um but here we go um just make sure that
it works for you guys if it doesn't I'm
not sure why it just stopped working for
me it tried to get the wrong node for
some reason I'm not I'm not sure why
anyways make sure that works for the
shops just a quick
um
bug fix I suppose I'm in our shop UI we
have to actually make sure that this is
on always for the promote process okay
and now let's make sure we add our shop
back in and let's try to test this again
so now we can go to our shop by finding
it here there we go and now we find our
staff our Green Arrow and our iron mace
and there we go so now we have a bunch
of things that we can transition between
so this is a staff with the cost and all
that now if you want to go from the this
one to the first right all we have to do
is actually
go to let's go to our shop and and try
to figure this out yourself actually I
want you to try to figure this out
yourself and I will give you the
solution if you keep watching so
hopefully you've paused and thought
about yourself and unpause and now to
figure this out what we can do is we can
actually say if
um in in the switch item so what we want
to do is we want to check to see the
inventory size so when we switch or we
can either do it here or here let's do
it
yeah let's do it in the actual switch
item so what we can do is here what
we're going to probably be trying to do
okay let's try let's try to actually
print the select and see what we get so
let's print select and see what we get
in in terms of the select switch item so
let's go to our shop
so at the moment it's zero right so
let's go here we have one two three
three three three and it doesn't let me
go above three
because what's happening is it'll always
just end up resetting at three right
um so what we have to do is we have to
be able to go from three to one or three
to zero so what we can say because the
problem is actually select is at three
but we're not trying to find three we're
trying to find zero so
there's a lot of different things we can
do we can say if select is equal to
three we'll say select equals zero this
is a quick fix right because what we can
now do or check is to go to our shop
to what we'll get
is go back to staff
and it'll just constantly rotate and we
can select for zero and reverse now
this won't really work but what we can
do is instead say if select is equal to
zero what we can do is actually say
is
select
equals to inventory items dot size now
inventory.size is going to return
three right one two three okay so it'll
make select equal to
that final thing now here for the select
we can say is equal to size is equal to
three right so now when I'm not not
inventory sorry let's close that now
let's go to the shop
and now when I go from oh that's an
interesting bug from Green Arrow to iron
mace
um to stuff we can now rotate through
all the items
right and we can go backwards we should
be able to go backwards interesting
okay what we can try to do
select we might have to actually add it
in the previous so
or we might have to actually check the
current item instead all right sorry
about the mix-up the select we actually
have to check for negative one and then
the select we have to set it to the size
minus one because this position the
final position of the inventory items is
2 and not three so
just to kind of re
confirm with everything the reason why
it will never go above three for example
is because here we're setting current
item equal to select right so it'll even
if I keep adding to it it'll always
reset it to that previous number
essentially and here we'll reset it by
going from if we're at three we'll reset
it to zero if we're at negative one or
if we're trying to go to negative one
we'll reset it at two right so select
will now be equal to two now this is
adaptable to the size of the inventory
okay or the sides of the item so the
more items I add it won't matter this
will adapt no matter what so this is a
really nice way to do it all right last
up is the purchase button so here is
actually pretty easy so all we have to
do firstly is check the price with how
much money we have so what we can do is
say
if the
inventory gold or I guess game gold is I
gotta capitalize this
make sure that we reference the correct
gold so if we say if the gold is greater
than the item inventory we can also do
equals so it's up to you really if you
want to have one more gold or the exact
amount of the cost of the item that we
currently have selected then all we have
to do is say inventory dot by or um add
item and then we have to find the
current selected item so the current
selected item has a is a number but what
we want to do is first find it and
that's it and what we actually do is we
actually do that right here so we say
we can copy this and say the if the I is
in range or so we're going to for Loop
through our inventory find the select
the selected item well in this case
we're not going to use select we're
actually going to use
um current item so I'm going to say if
current item is equal to I then we found
the item in our inventory size right or
our items from here we can say
here we'll take the name
or if anything actually we could just
get the name here we should just do that
instead we'll say
string
that there we go that'll actually make
this a lot easier let's just remove that
or we could have done what we did
previously and get the name if that
doesn't work actually we'll do this so
This should work though so let's
actually try this and that should work
so let's actually just go to our well
it's not going to work because
we don't have enough gold so we're
probably going to want to add more gold
give us ourselves a thousand gold
let's go to the shop which is somewhere
around here here it is so they have a
thousand gold the cost of the staff is
100.
and what do we get
we gotta convert this to a string or um
an INT so we'll say and
and then let's also convert this to an
end
um yeah so it's trying to convert a or
it's trying to compare an internet
string which is not going to work so
let's try one more time
and let's try purchasing and okay so we
didn't reduce the gold but it should
have showed up in our yeah there it is
so we had two but now we have three so
now let's actually reduce the amount of
gold so let's go back here and let's say
game.gold is minus equal
the cost now the cost is going to be the
fun part because now we need to actually
find the cost which
we can actually just say minus equal
this
and I think that's it so let's play
and whoops let's close the inventory
let's go to the shop
let's go open the shop here we go here's
our stuff let's buy this and boom what
do we get it's trying to re uh so this
is a string we got to convert it to an
INT I have to say int
there we go one more time
all right now we try one more time
and there we go so now we've reduced the
amount of gold let's try buying a green
arrow as well in Iron mace
let's close this and here we go so we
have a bunch of iron bases some green
arrows and that's it so now we can equip
these and it works perfectly fine so we
now have the we can equip the staff and
we'll go back into that let's see if the
Green Arrow works and it doesn't but um
I think that's because we didn't help
make it work so that's it that's the
shop working all right so the first
thing we're going to do is for our save
system we have to create a script for
this so This is actually relatively
simple let's actually close all our
scripts let's now close all these scenes
that we have open because everything we
have so far is pretty much finished so
in our global folder we're going to
create a file
called utils I call this utility folder
and I put all the utility stuff in here
so
um
well in this case we'll have save and
load so the first thing we're going to
do is create a save and load save pass
save path and password password is going
to be password please don't name yours
password because this is not very secure
and we're going to create a function for
Save
and we're going to have a load function
okay so for our save function we're
going to create a file
and we do that by saying a variable file
equals access dot open save path with
file access right now let's look through
this so the first thing we have to
understand is file access this is
basically calling so in good O3 actually
let me take a step back and go to three
and before you would have to create a
file by saying file access uh dot new
create the file so that that new would
create a new file but now this actually
allows us to create it like
automatically or it's more so it'll open
it if we have something if we don't
it'll create it for us okay so that
creates or opens the file okay so here
we're going to open at the path with
this
um
access if that makes sense so here we're
going to write in it right because we're
saving we're going to write inside that
file we're not going to do something
else like read that's going to be for
the load so here next line we're going
to create a j string file called Json or
when I set it to
json.stringify the inventory dot uh
inventory so we're going to stringify
our inventory now this works really well
because we're just going to take our
dictionary of our inventory and just
stringify it and that's it okay
next we're going to go to file dot Store
LINE j string so now all this is it this
is our save file
um basically we're just going to store
our j string inside of our file and
that's it now you used to have to close
it but now you don't I think it just
closes automatically which is really
nice so next up in our load
we're going to do the same thing but
we're going to read the file okay so
we're going to do the exact same thing
we're going to get the file that we have
and we're going to read it okay so this
would do the same thing it would make a
new one but because we should already
have one we should have already saved by
now then we'll just open what we have so
far okay
now the first thing two things we want
to do is to check if file is empty if
not file meaning if file is invalid then
we're going to return a file is also
equal null then I return so I put these
I think realistically you only should
need one of them but um a while ago when
I was working on my own game and I was
trying to use this for some reason it
would pass this but not this and it
would return on asking if null is file
whereas file is null so I just added
both I'm not sure why but maybe they
fixed it either way I just add both it's
basically a double check to to make sure
that we actually pass through the proper
file because now what we're going to do
is we're going to check if the file
exists
so I'm going to say a file exists at
save path this is like a triple check
essentially then we're going to actually
start loading it and the way we do that
is we're going to say if not and a file
is reached then we're going to do this
thing in here it's almost like a while
loop okay in fact um I used to use a
while loop but that would cause a few
errors and here so now what we're going
to do is create a variable called
current line is equal to json.parse
string file.getline
now what this does is it'll essentially
essentially take our j string and pop it
in here it'll go from a Json file into a
variable that we can actually read okay
so in fact what we can do here let's
start testing this right away let's go
into our player or something
sure let's go to let's do this in our
player let's do save well utils dot save
game
first of all let's actually Auto load
our script so let's go here Auto load
the utils
and add it
and now we should be able to save game
there we go
and let's actually load it as well
utils.load
and now
what we can do is in our utils we will
print the current line so let's say
print current line and then let's play
into what we get
okay so here we can see we have zero and
a bunch of other stuff
um one so we have two items let's see if
that's true yeah we have two items we
have count two of the staff and that's
it so we yeah it says staff over here
and that's pretty much it so
in fact we can see this file by going
into open in file manager and we can go
over here to
save game bin open it up and and now we
can see the Json that we saved in here
now it's a little hard to read because
it's all in one line but that's okay
because we don't actually need to change
this manually or we don't need to read
it manually so but now we can see that
it exists it saved the file and so this
is the file that we've created
and now we can actually load it back in
to our game right so the way we can do
that is actually pretty simple
well it's not but let's try to make it
simple so first we're going to for Loop
through our current line okay we're
going to for loop I in current line and
what this does is it'll actually go from
zero to one I believe
okay
and it'll basically print so if I were
to print here let's do this let's print
current I
and it should print this dictionary
and this dictionary
okay hopefully if it doesn't then I'm
surely
okay there we go so it did it printed
the first one like I had zero and then
position two or one in this case which
is the second item okay so now we can
actually reference something by saying I
at name right so now it should print the
name of everything so like the staff or
whatever right so now it'll print staff
and iron maze now you might be thinking
well this is really useful why well
because now all we would have to do is
say
inventory add item at the current line
now this won't this won't actually work
I think because oh no it will work let's
try this and see what happens
so we've saved and loaded meaning we've
essentially doubled what we have so we I
think we originally had two in one
and we loaded in one each now the reason
why this doesn't work perfectly is
because we're only adding one of
everything right so if I have but in the
in the case of our
save game save game here you can see we
have count two so we want to also make
sure that we load in the proper account
so we can for loop again and for Loop X
in the current line of the count and
then add that many times now make sure
that you convert this to an integer
because
everything that's stored as a Json
becomes a string so a Json is is
essentially a string a big long string
okay so when we turn it from a Json back
into a variable everything becomes a
string so we have to convert it back
into an integer well for in this case if
we
we don't actually convert it back into
an integer but we we need it as an
integer to actually make this for Loop
function because otherwise it'll error
so you can test it out yourself try it
without converting it and see what
happens on your side so now what we can
do is we can actually go here and take
out the save and we would only want to
save if we buy something or something
right so let's play the game Let's load
and now we can see here we have four and
two so let's close this let's go to add
item nope add item
and let's remove
the parts where I add items here we go
this is where I add a few things
and in our shop
let's actually go here and say
utils.save game
and
what else
and I think that's it so now we should
be able to play the game
if we load it up we now have two and one
now let's go to buy something let's go
buy something
okay so let's buy some staffs
some green arrows some maces
and now we have five four and three so
let's close that
and close the game it should have saved
because we bought some things so now
let's load open the game and as you can
see the inventory has saved and loaded
so that's awesome our inventory works
completely fine now if you want to save
and load the equipment you would do the
exact same thing and you would have to
handle the loading of the equipment as
well so
I would urge you to do that on your own
and hopefully you are at the point where
you can do that on your own if not I
would urge you to revise the inventory
the entire inventory
tutorial and series and lectures so
definitely go over them again if you
don't know how to do this again in the
in the equipment to either save and load
it and handle it in the actual equipment
Okay so
that's it for saving and loading we will
probably clean up the game a little bit
more mainly in the UI in the next part
so stay tuned and we'll get right into
that okay so for our UI I've decided to
use this
um if you find something else that you
would like that's totally fine but I'm
going to be using this as reference and
I'll be showing you how to set it up for
your game no matter what texture you
have I'll be showing you how to do it
perfectly uh fine so I'm going to be
probably using this one for reference we
even have like
um the armor inventory and stuff like
that I've downloaded these two and one
more you can find the previous golden UI
as well I'll show you them in a second
but yeah I've downloaded
all those for reference so let's go back
into our game and so here I can you can
see that I've downloaded them I have
yeah I'm not going to drag them in but
let's actually open up
um no let's not open up anything let's
create a new resource and we're going to
scroll down
or we're just gonna look for theme there
we go and then we'll set this as BG or
yeah I'll set this as BG
save it and in the BG what we'll do is
we'll open this up let's go to our 2D so
we just have a cleaner setup we'll go to
manage items
we'll go to edit import items import
items sorry we'll search up a panel
we're going to import the panel we're
also going to search up a button
we're going to import our button and
what else did we have let's import those
two for now and let me double check
what else we should have so in our let's
actually open up our UI so here we have
the
yeah actually I think that's good so
let's go to our BG let's go to our panel
and for the panel this one is going to
be easier so let's create a new style
box texture so every time you have a
texture box this is what you would use
now the other ones are the the flat is
something useful that's if you want to
change the color so you can actually
click this and just see that we can
change the color like this it's not
going to change it in fact what we can
do is
let's let me I'm going to set this by
doing this I'm going to set it by adding
it here and here we go so now you can
see that it's red but we don't want this
so what we're going to do is we're going
to use texture I'm going to go here and
we're going to drag in the texture that
we're going to use so let's actually use
the preview
so in the preview here you can see the
panel but we don't want that we want a
very specific part of this so for the
inventory let's say we want to use maybe
this one for example or this one so
let's go into our sub-region
and click edit region and this should
pop up
let me see if I can make it a little
bigger
okay there we go
there we go made it a little bigger so
we can zoom out and see and pick what we
want so this one actually looks quite
nice as a panel so let's use this one
let's go to
Auto slice and we can actually click
this sometimes if Auto slice doesn't
work you might have to use pixel snap or
Auto grid snap that might work nicely in
this case pixel snap is also quite nice
some it'll kind of snap to the next
pixel but I'm going to use Auto slice
because Auto slice actually works quite
nicely here sometimes it just doesn't
like for example this one if I wanted to
pick something which we actually will
use in a second we'll probably use this
for the Button Auto size won't work so
for here Auto slice we'll just do this
and we'll drag this down
to right around there and we'll drag
this here
we'll drag this dotted line here
and this dotted line here now what this
does is it essentially allows us to use
this as the border right and it won't
readjust it or it won't stretch it so
here you can see on our bottom let's
actually drag this up you can see the
label in the back was actually kind of
it's not stretched right but if I move
this you can now see that it's being
stretched as the panel is being
stretched so here we'll move this back
here like that and now we can see the
panel looks a lot nicer and cleaner and
so here you can see our panel it by
default looks a lot cleaner okay
now that's for the panel now for the
buttons let's go into style so button
style and let's look at normal so the
first thing we'll do is we'll clear the
normal and we'll create a box texture
we'll go to subregion edit region
well we're not going to edit anything
because we didn't drag it in so let's
drag it in and then edit
okay now here I'm going to use these
three as the button so this is going to
be the normal this is hover and this is
pressed so let's uh pixel snap and this
will be our normal so it's gonna this
might take a few tries to get right
because sometimes it doesn't Auto
it doesn't kind of drag where you want
it to be
so you have to kind of guess a few times
and then just drag it
there we go and oh
looks like I'm gonna have to try again
uh there we go
right okay cool so that's how we do that
and now we can just move this here like
that
and kind of drag this in the Middle
where we want it to stretch
and there we go so now you can see on
the bottom we have the button in fact
you can keep editing this to however you
like you can keep doing whatever and
kind of play around with it
maybe we can move that like this there
we go so here you can see the dots there
on the left and let's close that because
I think that's good for a button now
let's go to
hover and let's drag this in let's make
it unique and then let's drag it to
pressed and make that unique as well
now let's go to press first and edit
subregion and what we'll do it whoops
we'll select this one so we'll go to
pixel snap that's right
we'll hopefully select it properly
and there we go and the sub region is
almost selected properly for us there we
go
that looks right so let's close that
let's close it and here we can see the
the press button on the bottom and the
default buttons now we have hover so
this is when our Mouse is hovered over
the button so go to edit region
and we will use this one so let's
let's select this guy
there we go and now we'll move this to
the left a bit
and that looks nice so let's close
and now look for the focus what we'll do
we'll actually test this and see if it
works so let's go into our close button
and just
pop this as our theme
okay let's open it or let's play Let's
see what we get
here's our close button the text is a
little bit too much on the left or right
but that's okay so if you can see if I
hover it hovers it if I click it it does
that and that's it so if you
don't want the focus now there's a lot
of things you can play around with the
focus and disabled but for example if I
clear this
and I play again the focus means I just
clicked it or it's focused at the moment
right so if I click it
it doesn't really make a difference so
you can play around with the focus but
for the hover normal and press I think
that's good for the text there's not
really a good fix mainly because the
the text is aligned depending on what
the sub region that we just did right so
you could maybe
um go to let's go to a normal
let's go here uh
could maybe adjust this to go here like
that
but that would be a little weird
try this
no that won't really work because you
can see the middle is now all smudged up
so
yeah unfortunately it's you kind of just
have to play around with it maybe and
see what you get but this looks good to
me so
we'll we'll keep it like this and that's
it all right
um you can or you could alternately put
a label on top of this instead but for
now this is fine you'll have to adjust
to whatever you like okay next up is the
slots so for these slots instead of this
theme what we're gonna do is we're gonna
actually make let's duplicate this and
we'll say slot tress we'll go to the
slot here and we're going to select a
different one for the label specifically
so for the or the panel so let's go here
let's make it unique so we don't edit
the other one
let's go to the subregion go here and we
are going to select
this guy or there might be a separate
one a singular
cell
there is not so let's select one of
these guys
let's select
let's select this
this one might be a little hard to
adjust and kind of Select it wherever
you like I think I'll do right there
and the subregion looks good so let's
close it and now what I can do is I go
here and I'll drag in the slot theme and
it pops in like that we can move the
count a little bit to the left
so it looks a little more clean here we
go
let's save that and let's go to the UI
now what we can do is actually go to our
theme overrides constants and remove
that so let's play and see what we got
there we go there's our inventory it
looks pretty clean so we can actually
I'm going to adjust this off the screen
because it's a little hard to do
on the screen
we can do one or we can actually do zero
I think zero might work nicely yeah
there we go zero will make it look like
this which is a lot nicer now if you
want it really crisp you could just do
other things to make it look better but
for now this works fine for the slots in
the other one let's actually do that as
well let's go to the equipment and what
we'll do
is we'll go to yeah we'll just drag it
out honestly
oh sorry about that what we have to do
here is we'll kind of we can just select
all of them at once go to the theme and
drag in the slot there we go and now it
changes all of them and so you can
manually do each one and make it match
these but I'm a little lazy for that so
I'm not going to do that but I would
definitely recommend doing that if
you're going to make a complete game out
of this so next up I think we have the
shop so let's go look at the shop
no that's not true uh let's open the
shop but we'll go back to the inventory
real quick there is the item info that's
the one last thing we got to do so let's
go to the background we'll pop the BGN
for that the buttons will pop the BJ BG
in for the theme on that one
right the item the buttons awesome and I
think that is it so we have a nice clean
item info as well let's close this let's
go to the shop
we'll select all the buttons and pop in
the theme let's actually select the
background as well because we can just
pop it in for all of it and there we go
we now have an updated version of our
buttons so the the right and left might
not be what you want but that's okay I
think this is fine for now and it
definitely looks a lot cleaner than it
would it what it was before so our final
product looks like this we have a nice
little theme with our inventory and if
we go to the shop which is over here
it's like a little invisible here we go
here's our inventory or our shop so we
can hover and click things
which is really cool
awesome so hopefully now you understand
or know how to set your own theme in
Godot
awesome okay so the first thing we're
going to do is we're going to set the
texture for our
bars our HP stuff however the we have a
few issues so one of the main issues in
our bar for our actual Graphics in Godot
is going to be this guy so unfortunately
we need this to be connecting so in
graphic scale or whatever else you have
downloaded for Pixel editing we're going
to edit these like that and we're going
to go over here and do the same thing
so we can
copy paste and just fill it out and you
can do the rest as well we can also do
the let's do this guy as well
this one is mainly for this guy I
believe so we'll set up whichever one we
want but I'll set up both of them for
this okay
and this guy uh we will why don't we
just
yeah I'll just copy it
I will copy this one line over there we
go all right now it's everything is full
except for most of those obviously but
that's okay uh so now we'll save this
and we should be able to just close it
we'll go into our game
and what we'll do is we will
add a progress bar that I just deleted
so it's a little I'm a little sneaky so
we'll add the progress bar and in our BG
we're going to make sure that we add the
progress bar so make sure to import the
progress bar so import and import
selected I've already done this so here
it is so close it and in the background
of our texture what we'll do is we'll
drag in our new UI or our edited UI
so let's make this a little bigger and
then let's go to our progress bar and
actually drag in the theme BG so we
actually can affect it
and let's go to BG and we will go to
edit region and now let's pick a region
for our UI so I'm going to pick this one
I think because it's a little cleaner
then we're going to select the subregion
so it'll be
like this this one might be a little
hard mainly because of the shadowing but
that's okay
yeah
this one I'll put it like that
that
and I think that's good so we'll close
that and then for the so we'll close
this and we'll copy it to the fill we'll
make this unique we'll go to into here
and we'll go to the fill and we're just
going to pick the fill instead
let's zoom out a little bit so here it
is here's our fill so let's make sure we
select it properly
there we go
okay I didn't select it really properly
so
let me actually put on Pixel snap so
that I'm setting it properly there we go
and the subregion we will do
let's take a look at what it looks like
well we can't look at it because we
didn't we don't have a percentage so
let's randomly pick something and then
let's go to our progress bar and fill it
in so let's go to value and say 50
percent
okay now that looks horrible that's not
what we want at all so let's go back to
our BG
now the progress bars are always really
hard to mess with
because of the textures so honestly I
would I would recommend using texture
progress bar in other cases but if you
can set this up instead that's totally
fine as well so I'm going to do my best
to set this up with you guys so
hopefully we can do it together
let's try to find something that
is a little nice
okay
I might we might also have to mess
around with some other values in a
second but that's okay
so let's
find a value that fits okay there we go
put that right there actually
and that
put that there
no we obviously don't want that
let's put this right there
and that there okay so they're pretty
much on top of each other okay that's
fine now let's go to
not access stretch
does it expand margin nope
it's been a little while since I've done
this so
we're gonna have to
mess around with the values of this for
a little bit so let me actually pull up
my reference here so I don't spend 10
hours looking for it
here we go trust progress bar
style fill and
going to be
I remember how we do it okay this is
going to be a little tricky so
okay we can actually edit this in the
sub region so basically this rectangle
we need to we need to expand it outwards
a little bit so what we'll do is we'll
actually do this manually we'll go to
here and we'll
see if we can edit these values a little
bit
one by one we'll just drag them up and
down
and see what we get
that's obviously not what we want at all
because
we don't want that thing under us
let's push that up a little bit
okay what I'm going to do is I'm
actually going to open up graphic scale
one more time
and we're going to edit the
thing again and we're going to remove
this guy
because it's in the way
or I'll just move it down
okay so let's save let's go back to the
dough
and there it is it disappears so let's
edit this a bit more
all right there we go
okay
let's
let's just do this manually one more
time
so let's go over here
and let's make it pick like right there
like that
and then see what we get
okay let's move that
let's move that
and we need this guy to move a little
bit more to the left which I think we
can do here actually so let's do that
one more time let's
move this upwards
that looks good let's go to the left and
increase that nope
we'll go to six
we'll change it bit by bit
nope that's not what I want at all
so as you can see this is yeah this is
kind of a drag so again
the texture progress bar would be a lot
easier but in this case you would have
to separate it completely okay I think
this is good enough it's not perfect
because it overlays a little bit but
that's okay so if we move this up and
down
it at least looks like
kind of progressing in our progress bar
okay so let's actually set this to our
HP so let's rename this to HP
and give it a label
we'll do built-in it doesn't really
matter and this is really easy all we
have to do is say process value equals
to game.health
is it actually Health yes it is and the
max value we can set it to the max HP
which we don't have so we're going to
have to set that so let's go to game
and oh no we do Okay cool so that's it
let's now also add gold
this is also really easy I'll just have
a simple label right under it
actually no I'm not going to show you
because we have it in the shop I think
we also might have it in the inventory
if I remember
um
we don't let's add it to the shop or the
inventory then actually let's go over
here and add in a label
and this will be our gold so let's move
this over here and we'll rename it to
gold
and then we'll add a script built in
we'll go over here to the process and
the text will just be this so the
process will say text equals string game
dot Max Health Plus uh slash slash with
health no Okay I lied this is for the
gold okay
okay so this is gonna be our health hold
on
let's put this over here
foreign let's lock the progress bar I'm
losing my head right now it's really hot
where I am
so okay let's Center this Center this
let's expand it to be like that and
let's go to our progress bar and remove
show percentage and now when I play
hopefully it'll show my HP there we go
on the top left you can see my HP and I
don't think my HP can reduce so let's
actually go to our monster where's our
monster here we go skeleton and when he
hits us
where is that
on
oh I don't know if I ever do add an
attack do I
it should be over here
body.health so we'll say
okay let's make this unique because I
don't know if it is
let's make it unique
and save it and we'll say if player
in body dot name
then we will say game DOT health minus
equals five okay let's go to and let's
play
and let's see if this works and updates
if we get hit
and it's not so why is it
okay let's see
player
oh
um because there's no signal so let's
probably do that let's say body entered
let's connect it and now it's connected
now let's try one more time
it's all always the small mistakes all
right there we go now it's doing damage
to us
and there we go so now we have a working
RPG action RPG game it's really cool we
have inventories we have a shop we have
the UI on the top this is really nice
and we even have our little shop in the
corner I ended up just adding a little
um Mage into our
shop guy so it's nothing complicated
it's same thing it's just a shop with a
model now and that's it so I hope you
guys enjoyed
um that'll be it for now
congratulations everyone on finishing
the course this course was a really long
one it's five hours of grueling content
so if you were able to go through all of
it congratulations I really do
congratulate you and I hope you learned
so much from this course and in the
future
hope moving forward you guys are able to
take what you learned and create your
own game and I would love to see it so
going forward from here I have a YouTube
channel called codingquest or podcasts
you can check them both out I have many
many more tutorials and many more videos
on Game Dev that you can check out to
hopefully either inspire you or to help
you along your journey I also have a
Discord that you can check out if you
want to either share your projects or
ask for help or just chat with me you
can definitely check out my Discord
it'll be on my channel
at codingquests so check that out and I
hope to see you guys around goodbye